l'ordre du jour appelle donc la
discussion après engagement de la
procédure accélérée du projet de loi
adopté par le Sénat pour le plein emploi
la parole est donc à Monsieur Olivier du
soft ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion
très bien
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales Madame
et Monsieur les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver au début de
cette section extraordinaire pour
présenter devant vous le projet de loi
pour le plein emploi vous le savez
depuis 2017 sous l'autorité du Président
de la République les gouvernements
successifs et notre majorité poursuivent
un objectif majeur le plein emploi nous
voulons un emploi car nous sommes
convaincus que derrière cet objectif il
y a plus qu'un résultat statistique du
marché du travail c'est en réalité un
projet de société celui d'une société
plus productive et donc plus riche et
plus souveraine mais également une
société qui donne une place à chacun car
l'emploi nous l'affirmons nous le
réaffirmons l'accès à l'emploi reste le
meilleur moyen et l'outil le plus
efficace pour lutter contre la pauvreté
pour donner au rang de l'autonomie de la
dignité ainsi permettre l'émancipation
il y a encore quelques années parler de
plein emploi aurait suscité au mieux des
mots dubitatives au pire des sarcasmes
tant nous nous sommes habitués à vivre
avec le chômage de masse l'état
disait-on avait tout fait avaient fait
tout ce qu'il pouvait la puissance
publique était finalement dans une
impasse et une forme de fatalisme
collectif nous avait saisi conférence
plein emploi le rang d'une belle autopie
à l'horizon sans cesse repousse
ce fatalisme en réalité est mortifère et
il explique largement ce qui semble être
comme un décrochage productif quand on
constate après ces décennies de
résignation que notre taux d'emploi
reste plus de 10 points inférieurs à la
moyenne européenne quand on voit aussi
que notre produit intérieur brut par
habitant et 15 à 20% inférieur à ce que
l'Allemagne ou du Danemark revenir au
niveau de ses économies rarement
considéré comme des îlots ultralibéraux
ou de servitude un portrait à nos
finances publiques des recettes rendant
l'idée même des déficits totalement
inopérante et donc c'est pour faire
mentir tout cela que nous agissons
depuis 2017 nous avons fait une partie
du chemin ces 6 dernières années vous le
savez puisqu'en passant de 9,5 à 7,1%.
le taux de chômage est au plus bas
depuis 40 ans et le taux d'emploi le
taux d'activités sont au plus haut
depuis que l'INSEE les mesures en 1975
il reste encore beaucoup à faire mais
nous avons mis fin je crois à des
décennies de chômage de masse grâce à
une série de réformes ambitieuses menée
depuis 2017 pour faciliter l'accès des
jeunes à l'emploi nous avons fait la
réforme de l'apprentissage celle du
contre engagement jeune et nous avons
engagé la réforme du lycée professionnel
pour un site retour à l'emploi nous
avons fait la réforme de l'assurance
chômage pour continuer à améliorer le
taux d'emploi des seniors et le nombre
de personnes en emploi nous avons aussi
fait la réforme des retraites et c'est
aussi pour prolonger cet engagement que
nous souhaitons que les partenaires
sociaux puissent trouver un accord
interprofessionnel sur cette thématique
de l'emploi des seniors
finalement et surtout nous mettons un
terme au fatalisme ambiant qui a trop
longtemps dominé la question de l'emploi
en France au détriment de ceux qui sont
restés longtemps au chômage souvent les
mêmes toujours les plus fragiles d'entre
nous
aujourd'hui nous le croyons et nous le
savons nous sommes en mesure d'atteindre
le plein emploi et pour finir nos
données les moyens d'atteindre cet
objectif nous réformons donc le service
public de l'emploi nous modernisons
l'accompagnement des plus fragiles et
nous continuons à lever les freins à
l'emploi que connaissent trop de nos
concitoyens je pense notamment nous y
reviendrons à ceux en situation de
handicap
nous appuyons en réalité notre démarche
et ce texte sur un constat et une
conviction le constat c'est que les
entreprises peinent à recruter alors que
le chômage reste encore important parmi
les taux les plus importants en Europe
ça signifie que nous avons du mal à
résoudre cette inadéquation entre la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi et les
besoins des entreprises que nous devons
aussi donner plus efficacité à notre
service public de l'emploi pour faire se
rencontrer l'offre et la demande de
travail la conviction c'est que personne
n'est une employable et ce projet de loi
doit permettre au marché du travail
d'inclure ceux qui sont les plus
éloignés de l'emploi de rendre un emploi
au plus fragile c'est la même qui
pendant des décennies ont été relogées
au second au second rang par la fatalité
du chômage de masse souvent aux mêmes
endroits mais souvent les mêmes
avant de vous présenter les principales
dispositions du projet de loi que nous
défendons devant vous je souhaite
rappeler que les bases de ce projet de
loi reposent sur une méthode de
concertation et d'écoute ainsi le texte
s'inspire très directement du rapport de
la mission de concertation et de
préfiguration que j'ai confié à Thibault
guili au mois d'octobre dernier au
commissaire à l'emploi à l'engagement
des entreprises qui a mené une longue
concertation avec un certain nombre de
principes une dizaine que nous reprenons
et des dizaines de propositions que dont
nous nous inspirons pour être le plus
efficace possible le titre dédié aux
demandeurs d'emploi en situation de
handicap retranscrit lui les mesures
issues de la concertation menaient en
amont de la Conférence nationale du
handicap tenue par le Président de la
République le 26 avril dernier et qui
nécessite d'être inscrit dans la loi
faire preuve de solidarité ça n'est pas
accepté que se crée des trappes à
précarité et ça n'est pas atténué les
symptômes de la précarité qui en fait
disparaître les causes
c'est d'être accompagné globalement
d'être inséré par le travail dont ont
besoin les plus fragiles
je l'ai dit je me répète la République
n'est pas kite de son devoir de
solidarité quand elle a versé 607 euros
par mois à quelqu'un elle est quand elle
lui a rendu les moyens de son autonomie
et les moyens d'accéder à l'emploi et
avec ce projet de loi nous voulons donc
tenir pour de bons la promesse de
solidarité qui est celle du RSA et ce
avec une série de mesures concrètes
ne parlez pas de travail vous ne
connaissez pas
d'abord
l'ensemble des personnes en recherche
d'emploi et notamment
laisser monsieur le ministre s'exprimer
sur ce dont vous connaissez je n'ai pas
le sentiment que le travail et l'emploi
soit votre première spécialité
d'abord je le dis
l'ensemble des personnes en recherche
d'emploi et notamment l'ensemble des
allocataires du RSA des jeunes en
recherche d'emploi accompagnés par les
missions locales seront inscrites auprès
de l'opérateur France travail
c'est le meilleur moyen de garantir un
accompagnement à chacun et d'éviter les
ruptures de parcours pour les plus
isolés de préjeel loi prévoit la
reconnaissance et la sécurisation des
acteurs souvent associatifs chargé de
repérer d'aller vers les personnes qui
ne sont plus suivies aujourd'hui par
aucune structure pour leur proposer des
solutions d'accompagnement et
d'insertion adaptées comme l'insertion
par le sport par la culture mais pas
seulement bien sûr ces acteurs reconnus
seront intégrés au réseau France travail
pour qu'on ne perde aucune des solutions
qui marchent ensuite le parcours
d'accompagnement sera formalisé dans le
cadre d'un contrat d'engagement rénové
et unifié pour plus de lisibilité et
d'efficacité ce nouveau contrat
d'engagement sera proposé à tous les
demandeurs d'emploi quel que soit leur
situation il détaillera les engagements
réciproques de l'organisme référent et
de la personne accompagnée il intègrera
un plan d'action précisant les objectifs
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
du demandeur d'emploi et c'est important
de le souligner il tiendra compte de la
situation de la personne
après un diagnostic complet il pourra
d'abord être la personne pourra d'abord
être orienté vers un parcours à Visé
d'insertion sociale si c'est nécessaire
pour lever les freins rencontré en
matière de logement de garde d'enfants
de santé de mobilité avant le parcours
d'insertion professionnelle il sera par
exemple tenu compte de la situation des
proches des dons des familles
monoparentales qui n'ont pas de solution
de garde et je tiens d'emblée à
souligner que le Sénat enrichit le texte
sur ce point que j'ai pu constater
combien votre commission des affaires
sociales il est aussi attaché je crois
que nous allons réussir ce pari de
l'accompagnement rénové car nous
préparons ces nouvelles formes
d'accompagnement dans le cas d'une
expérimentation avec 18 départements je
les ai encore réunis vendredi dernier
pour faire le point sur la manière dont
cela se met en place et les retours sont
positifs notamment sur l'entretien
diagnostic réalisé simultanément avec
Pôle emploi et un travailleur social du
département
cette expérimentation est cette
intervention devant vous sont l'occasion
pour moi de saluer le travail
partenarial de grande qualité engagé
avec l'Assemblée des départements de
France et son président François
Sauvadet nous avons son nous écoutons et
en poursuivant le même objectif
d'insertion et le plein emploi ces
expérimentations dans 18 départements
s'appuie sur des initiatives locales
confort des outils souvent efficaces et
nous allons les poursuivre et les
élargir en 2024 pour préparer l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi des débuts 2025 il
s'agit d'anticiper de connaître les
pratiques les plus efficaces qui
relèvent de la gestion et non de la loi
pour réussir cette généralisation et
nous aurons l'occasion avec les
départements en expérimentation de faire
un premier bilan d'étape début 2024
ensuite le régime de contrôle et de
sanction des allocataires du RSA sera
rénovée pour être plus progressif mais
aussi plus effectif
un nouveau premier niveau de sanction
est introduit la suspension
remobilisation qui permettra de
suspendre temporairement la location au
manquement sans interrompre
l'accompagnement et si la personne
respecte ces engagements elle
bénéficiera d’inversement rétroactif des
droits à défaut il ira malheureusement
vers une radiation du RSA comme c'est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui comme c'est le
cas depuis 1988
cette nouvelle sanction sera exercée par
le président du conseil départemental
dans le temps respect de ces
prérogatives et de ses compétences enfin
dans l'esprit du contrat d'engagement
jeune ce nouveau contrat permettra de
proposer un accompagnement intensif et
personnalisé pour les allocataires du
RSA les plus éloignés de l'emploi France
travaille proposera ceux qui ont le plus
besoin selon ce que permet leur
situation personnelle jusqu'à 15 à 20h
hebdomadaires d'activités consacrées à
leur parcours atelier formation
accompagnement appuie solution locale il
s'agit de travail gratuit ni de
bénévolat obligatoire mais bien
d'activité d'insertion et de formation
pour permettre le retour à l'emploi cet
accompagnement sera aussi renforcé par
la prise en compte des difficultés de
nature sociale qui empêchent le retour à
l'emploi ces freins à l'emploi feront
l'objet d'un diagnostic complet pour
répondre précisément et c'est bien tout
l'enjeu du partenariat qui doit nous
permettre d'apporter des solutions
concrètes
je sais que cette question des 15
amateurs d'activités a suscité beaucoup
de débats pendant la Commission et avant
la commission permettez-moi de dire ma
conviction plus nous aurons
d'allocataires concernés par ces 15
amateurs d'activités et mieux ce sera
mais nous devons aussi tenir compte tant
de la capacité des personnes
accompagnées souvent dans de très
grandes difficultés après des années de
précarité parfois même des difficultés
de santé que de la capacité que nous
aurons collectivement à proposer partout
et à tous ces activités adaptées
personnalisées enfin pour cet
accompagnement puisse s'intégrer une
offre de formation adaptée je saisis
l'occasion de ces débats pour dire
confirmer que nous renouvelons le
principe d'une contractualisation pure
annuelle entre l'État et les régions
pour la formation des demandes en emploi
avec un plan d'investissement dans les
compétences aux côtés et en complément
de l'investissement des régions je viens
à cette égarde annoncer à région de
France et au président de région que
l'État est prêt à investir près de 4
milliards d'euros entre 2024 et 2027
alors côté et je suis heureux que les
régions accompagnent et amplifie cette
mobilisation continue en faveur de
l'emploi
heureux aussi que ce travail commun
amène cette région cette région sur les
régions métropolitaines a participé au
préparer des protocoles de préfiguration
de France travail chacune dans leur
territoire nous avons communiqué
ensemble avec l'ARF pour dire comment
nous allons avancer et préparer la
seconde génération du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
car nous le savons et nous le partageons
former ramène vers l'emploi et atteindre
le plein emploi on passera aussi par la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi et la
réponse aux besoins de compétences des
entreprises dans ce cadre priorité sera
donnée à l'insertion des publics
fragiles à la formation pour les métiers
en tension pour les formations à
distance et aux formations courtes avant
embauche priorité sera aussi donné à
l'élargissement des publics
bénéficiaires des formations financées
dans le cas du plan d'investissement
dans les compétences en supprimant les
conditions de diplôme et de formation
pour les allocataires du RSA et les
demandeurs d'emploi en situation de
handicap mais aussi en passant de
formation inférieure au bac à des
formations inférieures à bac + 2 pour
tous les autres demandeurs d'emploi
le second volet de ce projet de loi que
je présente devant vous vise à
l'amélioration de la gouvernance du
service public de l'emploi c'est là
aussi un chantier essentiel puisque les
remontées de terrain témoignent toutes
d'une difficile adaptation problématique
locale et d'un sentiment que les acteurs
ça parlent pas assez entre eux bien
entendu beaucoup d'initiatives
fonctionnent il s'agit les conforter
mais ne vous pouvons aller plus loin et
ainsi pour commencer le projet de loi
définit un patrimoine commun au membre
du réseau pour le coordonnées ce
patrimoine rassemblera des méthodes des
règles de coordination des critères
d'inscription d'orientation des
référentiels métiers ou de formation
mise en commun et partager par tout le
réseau des acteurs de l'emploi de la
formation et d'insertion concrètement
cela sera rendu possible à la mise en
réseau des systèmes d'information pour
partager les données en tracteur et
ainsi le système d'information de Pôle
Emploi évoluant une plateforme France
travail facilitante le travail et
l'accès à l'information de chacun des
acteurs
je veux aussi le souligner c'est la plus
d'informations pour les collectivités et
leurs élus avec des données agrégés sur
les parcours et les accompagnements dans
les élus ne disposent pas aujourd'hui et
qui leur seront régulièrement partagés
pour permettre des comparaisons ensuite
nous allons mettre en place une
gouvernance stéritorialisée et
simplifiée du réseau français travail
avec une base qui est le copilotage
entre l'État et les collectivités
locales à chaque échelon territorielle
pertinent en associant les partenaires
sociaux au niveau national et régional
cette gouvernance partagée reste le
moyen le plus sûr pour assurer la
cohérence du réseau tout en réduisant le
nombre d'instances existantes nous
allons donc créer une instance nationale
qui définira les orientations
stratégiques et les modalités de
pilotage du réseau France travail le
Comité National France travail au niveau
local des comités territoriaux assurant
un pilotage régional départemental au
niveau des bassins d'emplois à chaque
fois en copilotage avec les
collectivités
concernant les collectivités je vous
insister sur ce point France travail ne
réduit pas le champ de compétences des
collectivités locales j'ai veillé à ce
qu'aucun article ne remettent en
question la répartition des compétences
entre l'État et les collectivités pas
plus qu'entre les collectivités entre
elles ainsi les régions gardent leur
prérogatives de formation les
départements sur l'insertion les
communes et leurs intercommunalités sur
le reste de l'action sociale mais aussi
sur les questions de garde d'enfants de
mobilité ou encore de logement ainsi
l'État et les collectivités locales
auront conjointement la main pour
orienter l'action des opérateurs et des
partenaires du réseau ce n'est donc pas
moins de compétences pour les
collectivités mais plus de visibilité et
l'obtention d'un pouvoir d'orientation
plus fort sur l'ensemble des enjeux
d'insertion et d'emplois ainsi qu'une
meilleure visibilité des résultats des
politiques publiques menées sur chacun
de leur territoire
nous souhaitons que Pôle Emploi prenne
ton chat prenne en charge de nouvelles
missions au service de tous collectif ce
n'est pas non plus une recentralisation
bien au contraire Pôle emploi devenu
France travail devra mettre sa capacité
de soutien technique et opérationnel au
service de tous produire les commandes
les produire le patrimoine commun en
lien avec les acteurs concernés et comme
les autres opérateurs il inscrira son
action dans le cadre des orientations
arrêtées par la gouvernance nationale il
sera chargé finalement de mettre en
œuvre les orientations définies dans les
différents comités on sera l'opérateur
principal plus que le coordinateur et
sans lien de subordination à cet égard
le changement de nom de Pôle emploi en
France travaille témoigne de
l'importance du changement de
positionnement de Pôle emploi en visible
ça se transformation et par ailleurs je
le dis pour les autres acteurs du réseau
il y a parfois des inquiétudes qui sont
nées au début de la concertation qui ont
été levés c'est le cas pour l'émission
locale leur place est renforcée près du
public jeune elle continueront à jouer
le rôle central auprès des jeunes en
difficulté l'état continuera de
conventionner directement avec elle et
les collectivités seront toujours
présentes dans leurs instances de
coordination sans que ce soit modifié
leur gouvernance par contre en
participant au réseau à la définition
des orientations à la gouvernance le
rôle sera renforcé il n'est donc en
aucun cas question de fusion
enfin le troisième chantier du projet de
loi concerne la poursuite de
l'engagement pour l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap mais de
collègues y reviendront mais je le
souligne devant vous au titre des
politiques d'emploi les personnes en
situation de handicap rencontre encore
trop difficultés pour accéder aux
retourner à l'emploi et nous devons donc
prolonger les mesures mises en place au
cours du premier quinquennat d'abord
améliorer l'orientation professionnelle
des personnes en situation de handicap
en la confirme au service public de
l'emploi nous supprimons l'orientation
vers le marché du travailleur par les
MDPH et l'orientation en milieu
ordinaire devient un droit pour chacun
c'est le service public de l'emploi qui
proposera un accompagnement à toute
personne en situation de handicap sans
emploi et c'est uniquement en cas
d'impossibilité d'accès à l'emploi
ordinaire que sera préconisé une
orientation en milieu adaptée prononcé
par les MDPH de cas existe le cas
échéant
nous souhaitons ainsi mettre un fin
mettre fin aux orientations uniquement
sur la base d'un dossier par ailleurs le
ministère du travail aura en charge le
développement et la trajectoire de
l'emploi accompagné jusqu'à en 2027 pour
soutenir les personnes en situation de
handicap invisible enfin nous allons
améliorer l'accès au droit des personnes
en situation de handicap nous allons
notamment faire en sorte que les
personnes reconnues handicapées au titre
d'une pension d'invalidité ou d'une
rente d'incapacité et les mêmes droits
prévus dans le code du travail que les
personnes titulaires du RQTH sans passer
par la MDPH et notamment être recruté en
Entreprise Adaptée bénéficier d'emploi
accompagné ou avoir une rémunération
majorée en formation professionnelle de
la même manière mais là aussi mes
collègues mes collègues y reviendront
les conditions de travail des personnes
en ESAT évolueront et leurs droits
sociaux convergeront avec les droits
individuels et collectifs des salariés
nous voulons aussi favoriser
l'engagement des employeurs privés
publics certaines mesures certaines
mesures relevant du Code du travail
seront ainsi pérennisés comme le modèle
des Entreprises Adaptées travail
temporaires ou les contrats duré
déterminés tremplin jusqu'à leur
expérimentaux il y a un quatrième volet
dans le projet de loi autour des
services du service public de la petite
enfance mais ma collègue mise et
solidarité des familles ainsi que ma
collègue ministre d'éléguée en charge
des personnes handicapées ils
reviendront dans leur intervention et
enfin le dernier projet de loi prévoit
la transposition des mesures du texte au
territoire d'outre-mer sur ce sujet je
tiens à lui la qualité des échanges que
j'ai eu avec nombre d'élus ultramarins
je sais évidemment que tous les députés
préfèrent débattre rivoter ici mais les
spécificités des territoires d'outre-mer
rendent difficilement matériellement je
veux dire matériellement difficile dans
des batteries Simon les ordonnances que
nous proposons seront écrites en lien
avec les parlementaires d'outre-mer avec
les présidents des collectivités
concernées comme je l'ai indiqué
vendredi dernier au président du conseil
départemental de la Réunion qui
participent à l'expérimentation en
matière d'accompagnement des
allocataires du RSA
je termine par un mot mesdames et
messieurs les députés sur les moyens
financiers car en effet ce projet de loi
devra mobiliser des moyens financiers
conséquents sur toute la durée de sa
mise en place afin d'être efficace
ainsi pour atteindre le plein emploi
nous savons qu'il nous faut créer 700
000 emplois d'ici 2027 et c'est
atteignable à condition de sonner la
mobilisation générale c'est d'autant
plus atteignable que nous avons déjà
créé l'économie à créer un million 700
000 emplois au cours du premier
quinquennat et donc nous devons
accompagner plus intensivement investir
plus fortement encore pour accompagner
vers l'emploi celles et ceux qui sont
restés sur le bord du chemin
ce retour à l'emploi est rentable pour
les finances publiques au-delà de la
question de l'emploi et de l'insertion
car accompagner les personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi et moins coûteux
que le chômage de longue durée et
augmente l'activité en retour donc les
moyens de l'État nous allons mettre des
moyens pour atteindre cet objectif dès
2024 le projet de loi de finances vous
proposera d'augmenter les moyens de Pôle
emploi de 300 millions d'euros avec une
montée en charge progressive pour que
cela représente une augmentation de
moyens de 1 milliard d'euros par an en
2027 ces financements seront en partie
un effort de l'État et en partie issue
de la contribution de l'inédith à Pôle
Emploi puisqu'elle est les économies
permissent par les réformes de
l'assurance chômage la trajectoire la
trajectoire d'excédent de l'inédits ne
permet largement je pense et je l'ai dit
aux partenaires sociaux rencontrés en
cette rentrée que notre budget est un
budget de plein emploi qui implique
aussi de mobiliser les excédents issus
des réformes portées par le gouvernement
pour les réinvestir dans les politiques
d'emploi et de formation plutôt
qu'augmenter l'endettement public
par ailleurs dans le cadre du
partenariat qui nous unit avec les
conseils départementaux l'état proposera
au département une contractualisation
spécifique à hauteur de 170 millions
d'euros en 2024 pour accompagner la mise
en place de France travail avec un
partenariat dans chaque département pour
préparer la transition vers un nouveau
modèle et conforter nos stratégies
d'insertion mais aussi pour conforter
élargir les expérimentations avec les
départements volontaires
mesdames et messieurs les députés vous
allez vous saisir d'un texte qui a
évolué il a évolué au Sénat avec des
évolutions positives comme la prise en
compte des proches des dents ou des
représentants des usagers il a aussi
évolué au Sénat avec une importance plus
importante plus forte donnée à la
réponse aux besoins de recrutement des
entreprises notamment sur le lien avec
l'éducation nationale ou encore avec la
pérennisation l'organisation de l'emploi
accompagné sous forme de plateforme
départementale la semaine dernière votre
commission des affaires sociales à son
tour fait évoluer le texte notamment sur
la question des 15 20h d'accompagnement
pour apporter des précisions sur leur
mise en œuvre mais je ne doute pas que
le débats vont nous permettre de
continuer à avancer et à améliorer sa
disposition il a aussi déclarifié la
question du nom de l'opérateur et du
réseau pour ne pas risquer la confusion
que pointer un certain nombre de
sénateurs nous souhaitons que Pôle
emploi se transforme en France travaille
et puis ainsi animer le réseau des
acteurs de l'insertion et de l'emploi
votre commission aussi fait le choix de
ne pas revenir sur la suppression de la
charte d'engagement mais la remplacer
par une charte de coopération supprimant
la conditionnalité pour les
collectivités en matière d'accès à la
coupe résidence des instances de
coordination et c'est une bonne chose et
enfin vous avez enrichi la composition
du comité national France travail comme
des comités territoriaux ou encore
améliorer les formations réalisées
exclusivement à distance au bénéfice des
personnes en recherche d'emploi en
sécurisant cette assise juridique
en conclusion je voudrais simplement
vous dire que je crois que nous pouvons
être nombreux à nous rassembler sur ces
objectifs il ne faut pas avoir connu la
précarité pour penser que le statu quo
est une solution et il ne faut jamais
avoir été lu local pour considérer que
nous pouvons aller vers le Pôle emploi
sans la mobilisation tous les acteurs et
la prise en compte de la situation de
chacun je compte sur nos débats pour que
les ayons collectivement les outils
nécessaires à cette marge dans le Pôle
emploi je compte sur nos débat pour
continuer à enrichir et améliorer ce
texte
merci
la parole est maintenant madame Aurore
berger ministre des Solidarités et des
familles
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente de commission madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
puisque c'est la première fois que j'ai
l'honneur de m'exprimer dans cette
émission en tant que ministre des
Solidarités et des familles
permettez-moi de vous dire l'émotion qui
est la mienne d'autant plus sur les
sujets que nous allons aborder à la fois
nos tout-petits et la question du
service public de la petite enfance et
aussi la question d'une société plus
inclusive pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
solidarité famille se sont deux mots
évidemment qui rythmes le projet de loi
tel qu'il vous est présenté solidarité
famille parce que ce texte parle de ce
finalement de ce que nous avons de plus
précieux nos enfants nous tous petits
enfants la manière avec laquelle nous
les considérons dans notre société la
manière avec laquelle nous pouvons en
toute sécurité évidemment avoir recours
à la garde d'enfants et puis la manière
avec laquelle nous considérons et nous
prenons en compte le handicap dans notre
société la ministre déléguée Fadila
katabi il reviendra bien évidemment mais
je crois que nous pourrons et je
l'espère à l'unanimité accepter qu'enfin
les personnes qui travaillent en ESAT ne
soient plus considérées comme des
usagers mais bien comme des travailleurs
avec donc le droit commun qui doit
pouvoir s'appliquer à eux je crois que
c'est une avancée extrêmement importante
dans ce projet de loi
la question du service public de la
petite enfance est donc de l'article 10
et de l'article 10 bis voudrait y
revenir et essayer de répondre à un
certain nombre de questions qui se sont
en fait jour soit évidemment au Sénat
soit dans la commission des affaires
sociales au sein de laquelle j'étais la
semaine dernière je crois pour démarrer
que tout d'abord oui bah même à 1h30 du
matin on siège et les parlementaires
sièges et les ministres sont à la
disposition du Parlement quelle que soit
l'heure à laquelle commission ou
hémicycle évidemment siège
le service public de la petite enfance a
été pendant trop longtemps repoussé et
je crois profondément que c'est le
service public de la petite enfance a
été pendant trop longtemps repoussé
c'est parce que finalement ce qui se
passait pour les enfants entre 0 et 3
ans pendant longtemps l'intéressait pas
particulièrement en général notre
société et je dis à société au sens très
général que ce soit notre hémicycle que
ce soit les parlementaires que ce soit
les élus que ce soit les politiques
publiques et heureusement il a fallu
Maurice Cyrulnik il a fallu des
chercheurs des sociologues des
éducateurs des encadrants des
auxiliaires de puériculture des
éducateurs des jeunes enfants il a fallu
des professionnels pour nous alerter
évidemment et pour nous dire à quel
point ce qui se passe entre les héros et
trois ans de nos enfants ce qui se passe
dans les 1000 premiers jours de la vie
de l'enfant est évidemment absolument
déterminant pour la construction future
de nos enfants leur sécurité évidemment
physique et affective leur développement
futur et donc la capacité qu'ils auront
à être demain évidemment des enfants des
adolescents et des adultes pleinement
ancrés dans notre société je sais que
certains se sont étonnés que dans ce
projet de loi on retrouve la question du
service public de la petite enfance
pourquoi un projet de loi sur le plein
emploi devrait-il faire le lien avec le
service public de la petite enfance et
pourtant c'est intimement lié intimement
lié quand on croit à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes notamment
intimement liés parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
sont 160000 personnes et en gros 160 000
femmes disons-le qui renoncent à
l'insertion professionnelle qui renonce
à la reprise d'activités
professionnelles parce qu'elle ne trouve
pas aujourd'hui de solutions de garde
d'enfants donc si nous voulons rompre
justement avec ce cercle vicieux si nous
voulons garantir l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes alors nous devons
garantir à toutes les familles l'accès à
une solution de garde d'enfant c'est
donc pour cela que cet enjeu est
pleinement ancré dans ce projet de loi
sur le plein emploi
dans
dans quel contexte dans quel contexte
des battons-nous nous débattons dans un
contexte nous le savons de pénurie de
professionnels et en vérité la pénurie
de professionnelle elle engendre la
pénurie de professionnelle parce que
celle qui reste elle est encore je le
mets au féminin parce que ce sont
majoritairement des femmes et bien ce
sont elles qui sont en perte de sens ce
sont elles qui sont parfois en burn out
ce sont elles qui sont dans des
situations professionnelles alarmantes
ce sont elles qui ont besoin beaucoup
plus qu'auparavant de reconnaissance de
revalorisation et de nouvelles manières
d'appréhender leur métier parce que oui
là encore pendant trop d'années on a
considéré que travailler dans le secteur
de la petite enfance n'était pas un
métier à part entière c'est un métier
c'est une formation qui est nécessaire
parce que oui on confie ce que nous
avons de plus précieux quand le matin on
confie ses enfants à un professionnel de
la petite enfance et cette pénurie c'est
aujourd'hui 10 000 professionnels déjà
qui manquent à l'appel dans l'ensemble
de nos structures et qui risque de vous
savez c'est nous ne prenons pas les
décisions qui s'imposent aujourd'hui
puisque ne serait-ce que pour les
assistantes maternelles 120 000
assistantes maternelles partiront à la
retraite d'ici 2030 vous voyez donc la
marche énorme qu'il nous reste
impérativement aggravir et donc la
première urgence c'est la revalorisation
des professionnels cette revalorisation
des professionnels les tailles consacre
des moyens sans précédent qui sont
documentés validés ça s'appelle la
convention d'objectifs et de moyens que
notre ministère signe avec la CNAV ce
sont 6 milliards d'euros qui seront
déployés entre 2023 et 2027
spécifiquement pour construire le
service public de la petite enfance cet
historique ça n'est pas moi qui le dit
monsieur le député mais la présidente
justement de la CNAF qui attendait
depuis des années cette revalorisation
et je crois qu'en effet c'est bien que
nous ayons eu le courage et
l'opportunité de le faire
pour garantir une meilleure organisation
du temps professionnel pour garantir la
revalorisation des professionnels pour
garantir leur mobilité professionnelle
leur reprise d'ancienneté quand elle
passe d'une structure à une autre je
crois que là c'est la manière avec
laquelle l'État doit agir fléchit
l'argent public pour garantir son
utilisation et garantir surtout qu'il
tire vers le haut l'ensemble des
politiques publiques en faveur de la
petite enfance
que va changer concrètement si vous en
décidez ce projet de loi il a deux
articles sur le service public de la
petite enfance le premier c'est d'abord
enfin qu'il y ait un pilote sur ce
service public de la petite enfance et
en cela oui cette loi elle est une loi
de décentralisation elle est une loi qui
garantit Homère la liberté d'agir et les
moyens d'agir pour être à la tête encore
une fois de l'autorité organisatrice du
service public de la petite enfance nous
avons travaillé nous avons concerté que
ce soit en lien évidemment avec les
apports du Sénat ou que ce soit avec les
associations représentatives d'élus en
particulier puisqu'on parle des communes
à partir de 3500 habitants avec l'AMF et
avec France urbaine et donc nous sommes
arrivés à un compromis que je crois
absolument nécessaire pour garantir que
ce projet de loi puisse entrer en
vigueur dans les meilleures conditions
possibles oui revenir à un seuil de 3500
habitants pour garantir véritable
maillage territorial sur l'ensemble de
notre pays mais mais avec des conditions
adaptées pour les communes de moins de
10000 habitants qui n'ont pas évidemment
la même ingénierie que les communes de
plus de 10 000 habitants sur la question
de la date de l'entrée en vigueur pour
ne pas que ça se chevauche notamment
avec les élections municipales ce qui
était une demande importante des élus en
place la date du premier janvier 2025
sera retenu là encore avec des modalités
adaptés au 1er janvier 2026 pour les
communes de plus de 10 000 habitants qui
doivent mettre en place un relais petit
enfance et surtout l'idée n'est pas de
recentraliser je le redis de
décentraliser en donnant les moyens aux
communes d'agir ce qui veut dire un
soutien massif de l'État un soutien
massif non seulement financier la
convention d'objectifs et de gestion des
6 milliards d'euros que la cave va
pouvoir déployer en lien étroit
évidemment avec les collectivités comme
c'est déjà le cas mais aussi un soutien
en ingénierie parce que là encore nous
voyons bien l'écart qu'il peut y avoir
entre les différentes communes et puis
un article 10 que nous avons ajouté
alors oui dans la nuit mais que nous
avons ajouté en commission des affaires
sociales et que je crois absolument
déterminant puisqu'il s'agit de la
question des contrôles et de la capacité
que l'État a de pouvoir contrôler ce qui
se passe il y a à la fois les contrôles
qui sont fait directement dans les
établissements ces contrôles inopinés et
qui sont à la responsabilité vous le
savez des départements puisque c'est la
compétence des PMI que nous accompagnons
mais il y avait un trou dans la raquette
qui faisait qu'aujourd'hui l'état l'État
n'avait pas la capacité d'aller au siège
des grands groupes privés d'envoyer
l'IGF d'envoyer l'IGAS d'envoyer les ARS
pour avoir accès au livre de compte pour
savoir quelles étaient les contrats de
travail bref pour comprendre comment ces
groupes privés sont structurés soit
organisés et pouvoir les contrôler
efficacement c'est ça que permet
l'article 10 bis et je crois qu'il est
absolument déterminant j'ai d'ailleurs
convoquer les quatre grands groupes
privés des parutions des deux ouvrages
je les revois dans deux mois de manière
à voir de manière très précise ce qui
est mis en place nous avons besoin et je
leur ai affirme de tout le monde pour
garantir le service public de la petite
enfance par un modèle économique à la
place d'un autre mais cela signifie que
l'État doit en être le garant et que
l'État doit vérifier la qualité
d'accueil évidemment dans tous les
établissements pour nos enfants le reste
à charge pour les familles et la
sécurité évidemment de nos enfants j'ai
convoqué également et vu l'ensemble des
préfets des dettes la semaine dernière
de manière à ce que sous l'autorité des
préfets l'ensemble des données
disponibles à la disposition et bien des
préfets des services de l'État sont à
croisés pour que des contrôles plus
efficaces puissent être immédiatement
diligée donc je crois que réarmer réarmé
parce que vous avez des moyens qui sont
mis sur la table qui n'ont jamais été
mis sur la table auparavant avec 6
milliards d'euros en pluriel réarmé
parce qu'en fin on remet le coeur du
service public de la petite enfance la
question des professionnels de la petite
enfance et donc la question de la
qualité d'accueil et de la sécurité
d'accueil aux enfants et réarmer en
ayant les moyens de contrôler contrôler
dans les établissements et évidemment
contrôler directement les grands groupes
privés c'est ça l'objectif que nous
poursuivons avec ces deux articles qui
viennent presque conclure le projet de
loi je vous dis évidemment que
l'objectif est de poursuivre sur cette
méthode méthode évidemment parlementaire
j'ai dialogué avec l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires qui ont souhaité
nous soumettre des propositions nous
avons accepté des amendements de
l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires
qui ont voulu être constructifs et ce
sera le cas également évidemment en
séance publique et je ne doute pas que
ça puisse être le cas en lien avec le
Sénat parce que c'est comme ça que se
construisent les textes en lien aussi
avec toutes les associations
représentatives d'élus l'AMF que je
remercie et je remercie son président
d'avoir été extrêmement présent de
manière à ce que nous puissions avoir un
compromis avec France urbaine avec l'ADF
évidemment sur la question des contrôles
parce que les sujets qui sont devant
nous sont bien trop importants et trop
structurants je conclurai avec une
phrase que je trouve très belle et très
éclairante qui est écrivaine que vous
connaissez sans doute rebeccaliers qui
dit ceci sur nos enfants la seule chose
qui dure toujours c'est l'enfance quand
elle s'est mal passée on y reste coincé
à vie alors faisons enfant en sorte
surtout que nos enfants et la meilleure
des enfants de toute la sécurité
possible je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Fadila catabi
ministre délégué chargé des personnes
handicapées
merci madame la présidente madame
monsieur les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame
monsieur les rapporteurs madame et
Messieurs les Députés je suis moi aussi
très très heureuse de vous retrouver
dans cette hémicycle j'espère que la
pose estivale a été agréable pour parler
d'un défi qui me tient qui nous tient à
cœur j'en suis certaine à savoir
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes en situation de handicap une
de nos grandes priorités
mes collègues l'ont très bien expliqué
l'objectif de ce texte est bien sûr
ambitieux il vise à atteindre le plein
emploi pour tous les français pour cela
nous devons continuer à lever les freins
qui existent et qui sont encore trop
nombreux pour nos constituants en
situation de handicap si le taux de
chômage des personnes handicapées
étaient de 19% en 2017 il est descendu
en 2023 à 12%. grâce à l'action
gouvernementale et bien sûr
l'implication de notre majorité
je veux saluer à cet égard l'engagement
sans faille de mon collègue Olivier du
soft qui a su dans le cadre de la
Conférence nationale du handicap se
saisir pleinement de ce sujet c'est
cette méthode de travail rappelée
d'ailleurs par la première ministre
mercredi dernier lors du comité
interministériel du handicap qui doit
nous permettre je dis bien qui doit nous
permettre de rendre nos politiques
publiques plus efficientes et de faire
respecter les droits des personnes en
situation de handicap aussi cette
méthode a permis de faire émerger des
mesures ambitieuses pour l'emploi saluer
par les personnes concernées par les
acteurs associatifs et par les
entreprises ces mesures désormais
doivent être déployés et déclinés au
niveau législatif
c'est précisément donc l'objet de ce
projet de loi
concrètement cela commence avec une
meilleure orientation des demandeurs
d'emploi et une meilleure prise en
compte de leurs compétences et
aspirations afin de mieux sécuriser leur
parcours professionnel
demain grâce à France travail ce nouveau
service public de l'emploi sera la porte
d'entrée unique je dis bien unique pour
tous les Français en situation de
handicap ou non dans ces conditions
chaque demandeur d'emploi pourra être
informé orienté et accompagner dans son
projet professionnel par le biais d'un
conseiller avec Olivier dussobe et
Aurore berger nous souhaitons pouvoir
répondre aux aspirations des demandeurs
d'emploi en situation de handicap en
fluidifiant et en sécurisant leur
parcours
si les esats restent des acteurs majeurs
pour autant je dis bien pour autant nous
ne devons pas assigner à résidence des
personnes qui peuvent et qui veulent
aller en milieu ordinaire en d'autres
termes l'orientation en milieu ordinaire
sera de droit et exercer son métier dans
un ESAT sera un choix
sur la question des droits précisément
je me réjouis monsieur le ministre chez
Olivier de ces très belles avancées qui
incarnent un véritable progrès social
visant à aligner les droits des
travailleurs en ESAT sur ce des salariés
vous devriez plutôt vous en réjouir mes
chers collègues en effet cher députés
comment comment justifier qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont 120000 femmes et hommes qui
travaillent mais qui n'ont pas le droit
de faire grève qui n'ont pas le droit de
se syndiquer comment expliquer qu'il
n'est pas le droit non plus à une
complémentaire santé ni à la prime
transport ou encore au ticket restaurant
des avancées pourtant essentielles qui
permettront effectivement d'améliorer
leur pouvoir d'achat ces mesures que
nous portons ici par le biais de ce
projet de loi sont historiques je sais
que ça ne vous plaît pas mais je le dis
enfin plus largement ce projet de loi
contribue à changer le regard que notre
société porte parfois sur les personnes
handicapées un regard qui trop souvent
encore exclu un trop grand nombre de nos
concitoyens si les questions de prise de
conscience il est surtout question
d'égalité des chances et des droits oui
en tant que ministre des personnes
handicapées je revendique une société
véritablement inclusive qui considère
ses citoyens pour ce qu'ils sont
vraiment pour leurs compétences et leurs
aspirations je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant monsieur Paul Christophe
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît madame la Présidente la
parole est à monsieur le rapporteur je
vous remercie merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre mesdames les ministres
madame la Présidente de la Commission de
la part sociale madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues après 30 heures de
débats en commission des affaires
sociales l'examen de plus de 1130
amendements j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter une réforme équilibrée et
ambitieuse qui vise notamment à
intensifier l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi et des bénéficiaires
du revenu de solidarité active grâce à
une transformation du service public de
l'emploi la France peut se targuer d'un
marché du travail extrêmement dynamique
qui se traduit par un taux de chômage
historiquement bas à 7,2%. aussi lors du
précédent quinquennat 1,7 millions
d'emplois ont été créés et plusieurs
dizaines de milliers sont déjà
programmés de par la réindustriation
d'autres pays oui le plein emploi est
bien à notre portée pour l'atteindre
nous devons aider nos concitoyens les
plus éloignés de l'emploi et les chefs
d'entreprise à se rencontrer à titre
d'exemple 350
000 emplois sont restés non première vue
au quatrième trimestre 2022 et 61% des
recrutements ont été jugés difficiles
pour cette même année de fait
l'écrasante majorité des entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés ne disposent pas
d'un service de ressources humaines
alors qu'elle représente 70% des
embauches le raccompagnement est donc
crucial cependant faute d'une image à la
hauteur du service rendu Pôle emploi ne
capte qu'un quart des offres disponibles
c'est l'ensemble de ces enjeux que ce
projet de loi vous propose d'apporter
des solutions concrètes le principe de
l'inscription généralisée auprès de
l'opérateur France travail de toutes les
personnes aux recherches d'emploi ou
rencontrant des difficultés sociales et
professionnelles prévues à l'article
premier vise à améliorer l'orientation
des personnes parallèlement l'article 2
modifie le régime des droits et devoirs
des demandeurs d'emploi à travers un
contrat d'engagement réciproque tel que
précisé par la Commission
nous en sommes convaincus et ne vont pas
honte de le dire l'emploi reste le
meilleur moyen de sortir de la pauvreté
or jusqu'ici les contrats signés par les
allocataires du RSA ne formulent trop
souvent aucune action avisée d'emploi
par conséquent s'étend après l'entrée en
RSA seul 11% des bénéficiaires ont
trouvé un emploi durable nous ne pouvons
accepter que des personnes en capacité
de travailler ne puissent pas sortir de
la pauvreté faute d'un accompagnement
suffisamment intensif demain
l'allocataire et son référent pourront
par des objectifs progressifs et
raisonnables levez les freins à la
reprise d'un emploi et construire
ensemble un projet professionnel choisi
au disposition figure initialement dans
le projet de loi les sénateurs ont
ajouté une obligation d'activité d'au
moins 15 heures par semaine par voie
d'amendement nous avons collectivement
fait le choix d'assouplir cette formule
afin que la situation particulière du
demandeur d'emploi et les difficultés
qui le rencontrent notamment en matière
de santé de logement de mobilité de
garde d'enfants et tenant un situation
de proche aidant la prise en compte
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
je vois à travers ce dispositif du
dialogue et de l'écoute c'est d'ailleurs
les termes utilisés par les allocataires
du Pôle Expérimental de Tourcoing que
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer pour
remettre l'humain au coeur du dispositif
et favoriser un accompagnement intensif
pour tous le gouvernement prévoit un
budget de 2,5 milliards d'euros d'ici à
2027 se traduisant notamment par
l'ouverture de 300 équipes en plein
supplémentaire rien que pour l'année
2024 nous sommes conscients que l'échec
du système est aussi de notre
responsabilité c'est pour cela qu'un tel
investissement sur l'avenir est décidé
aujourd'hui néanmoins la locataire
s'engage aussi par la signature de ce
contrat sur des règles qu'il connaît dès
le départ puisqu'il participe à leur
définition en cas de manquement répété
il doit être sanctionné en gardant à
l'esprit que l'accompagnement reste
notre priorité absolue l'article 3
prévoit ainsi une nouvelle sanction dite
de suspension remobilisation
face à des entorses répétées du
demandeur d'emploi à ses obligations
l'allocataire aura la possibilité de
montrer sa volonté de reprendre son
parcours et les devoirs qui sont liés si
tel est le cas ses droits seront
restaurés et ces allocations lui seront
restituées cette règle est ainsi mieux
disante que celle qui aujourd'hui le
prive de tout reversement j'en viens à
présent au titre 2 qui constitue la
réforme du service public de l'emploi
les acteurs auditionnés ont tous
souligné l'effort de territorialisation
des politiques de l'emploi opéré par le
texte en effet l'article 4 crée un
réseau national réunissant l'ensemble
des acteurs de l'emploi de l'information
et de l'insertion autour d'une charte de
coopération commune visant à définir un
nouveau cadre pour l'exercice de leurs
compétences et ce dans le respect de la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales consacrées par l'article
72 de la Constitution dans un esprit de
consensus et de lisibilité la Commission
a choisi de différencier le nom du
réseau des acteurs de l'insertion et de
l'emploi de celui de son principal
opérateur France travaille dont
l'article 5 définit l'émission l'article
6 vise à mieux repérer les personnes les
plus éloignées l'article 7 vous l'avez
dit Monsieur ministre pour sa part en
concertation avec les régions à revenir
sur la formation à distance nous aurons
l'occasion de débattre puis une semaine
de la pertinence de cette réforme je
reste sur ma part persuadé qu'elle nous
permettra de mieux accompagner nos
concitoyens et ainsi de les aider à
sortir de la pauvreté d'une relance pas
l'idée de vous en convaincre je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Christine Le Nabour
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues je suis très heureuse de
rapporter les titres 3 et 4 de ce projet
de loi car il aborde deux sujets de
sujets qui me tiennent à cœur
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
des personnes en situation de handicap
et l'offre d'accueil du jeune enfant ce
texte comporte des mesures qui doivent
contribuer à atteindre l'objectif de
pleine emploi dans notre pays le bon
emploi pour tous et partout jamais notre
pays n'a compté autant de travailleurs
en situation de handicap aujourd'hui
c'est 1,1 millions qui exerce une
activité professionnelle le taux de
chômage est passé de 19 à 12%, le taux
d'emploi direct des bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi c'est améliorer
des résultats qui témoignent de
l'engagement de ce gouvernement et de
cette majorité à accélérer en matière
d'accès à la formation à l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
mieux c'est encourageant mais ce n'est
pas encore assez
nous devons mieux accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi en situation de
handicap il est encore trop compliqué
pour eux de trouver un emploi ou de se
maintenir dans l'emploi la réponse se
trouve dans la construction collective
d'un monde du travail dans lequel chaque
personne quel que soit sa situation doit
trouver sa place trouver un emploi qui
correspond à ses besoins et ses
aspirations évoluer dans son parcours
professionnel et contribue à la vie
économique du pays la réponse se trouve
également dans l'accompagnement des
entreprises et en particulier les TPE
PME sensibiliser former aider à recruter
et bien accueillir aider à adapter
l'environnement de travail l'article 8
pose le principe selon lequel
l'orientation en milieu ordinaire et
l'orientation de droit commun ouvert à
tous sans validation préalable c'est une
avancée considérable pour les personnes
en situation de handicap qui attendaient
plusieurs mois et qui était trop souvent
orientés automatiquement dans le milieu
protégé il élargit l'application des
dispositifs associés à la reconnaissance
de la qualité travailleur handicapé à
toutes les catégories de bénéficiaires
de l'obligation cela signifie que chacun
pourra bénéficier de ces dispositifs
tels que l'emploi accompagné ou l'accès
aux Entreprises Adaptées sans avoir
besoin de la reconnaissance formelle de
la commission des droits et de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
d'autres mesures ont été introduites au
sénates telles que le sac à dos
numérique pour faciliter la mise en
œuvre rapide des aménagements
nécessaires ou encore la portabilité
des équipements de compensation à
l'occasion d'une mobilité
professionnelle par convention entre
deux entreprises il transfère à l'état
la gestion de l'emploi accompagné et
pérennise les dispositifs expérimentaux
qui ont prouvé leur efficacité le CDD
tremplin et les Entreprises Adaptées de
travail temporaires l'article 9 propose
de faire converger les droits sociaux
des travailleurs handicapés en milieu
protégés des esats avec ceux des
salariés des mesures d'équité pour les
120 000 travailleurs en ESAT et qui
respectent les engagements
internationaux de la France en matière
de des droits des personnes handicapées
le manque d'offre de garde du jeune
enfant est un véritable frein à accès à
la formation et à l'emploi des parents
et en particulier des familles
monoparentales 160
000 personnes le plus souvent des femmes
renonce à chercher un emploi parce
qu'elle ne trouve pas de place d'accueil
pour leur enfant ce n'est pas acceptable
l'article 10 vise à conforter le rôle
des communes en matière d'accueil du
jeune enfant rôle qu'elles exerceront en
lien avec le département avec la
possibilité de déléguer cette compétence
à l'intercommunalité cet article a fait
l'objet de nombreuses modifices
modifications au Sénat puis en
commission des affaires sociales à
l'Assemblée en voici quelques-unes la
Commission n'a pas souhaité rétablir en
tant que tel les dispositions relatives
à l'élaboration de la stratégie
nationale toutefois elle a décidé que le
ministre chargé de la famille arrêtera
des objectifs de développement
quantitatif et qualitatif en matière
d'accueil du jeune enfant après
consultation des représentants des
collectivités territoriales de la CNAV
de la CCMSA de l'UNAF le Haut Conseil de
la famille de l'enfance et de l'âge et
des professionnels et gestionnaires des
structures et services concernés ces
objectifs seront indiqués dans le schéma
départemental des services aux familles
et feront l'objet d'un suivi annuel et
d'une évaluation plus réelle les régions
devront prendre en compte les besoins
nationaux de formation professionnelle
dans secteur de l'accueil du jeune
enfant en plus des besoins prévisionnels
de professionnels
la Commission a rétabli l'obligation
pour les communes de plus de 3500
habitants de mettre en oeuvre le schéma
pluriannuel de maintien et de
développement de l'offre d'accueil du
jeune enfant la question de
l'accessibilité financière et
géographique de l'offre d'accueil
notamment pour les familles confrontées
à des difficultés liées à leurs
conditions de vie ou de travail leur
état de santé la faiblesse de leurs
ressources sera prise en compte
introduit par un abonnement du
gouvernement
l'article 10 vise pardon introduit par
un amendement du gouvernement vise à
rénover les modalités d'inspection et de
contrôle des établissements d'accueil du
jeûne enfant alors mes chers collègues
je ne doute pas que ces articles soient
votés à l'unanimité parce qu'aujourd'hui
les personnes en situation de handicap
qui recherchent du travail nous
regardent et attendent les parents qui
n'ont pas de mode de garde aujourd'hui
nous regardent et attendre je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant madame
Charlotte Parmentier Lecoq présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres Monsieur
et Madame les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues c'est une joie de se retrouver
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle après la
suspension estivale et c'est une fierté
pour la commission des affaires sociales
de rapporter par la voix de Paul
Christophe et de Christine le nabourg un
projet de loi d'une telle importance la
commission des affaires sociales a
adopter le projet de loi la semaine
dernière après trois jours de séance et
1133 amendements soit 30 heures de
débats au cours desquels chacun a pu
s'exprimer et 216 amendements ont pu
ainsi être adoptés
je dois préciser que pour ce faire j'ai
souhaité que la Commission HF ces
travaux dans la nuit du mercredi au
jeudi afin de garantir comme l'exige la
Constitution que nous puissions débattre
aujourd'hui sur la base d'un texte que
la commission des affaires sociales
avait la responsabilité d'adopter cette
responsabilité a été assumée en tant que
nouvelle présidente de cette commission
et dans la lignée de mes prédécesseurs
jusqu'à madame Khattabi à laquelle
j'adresse mes pensées amicales je
l'affirme il n'aurait pas pu en être
autrement
nous disposons désormais de 8 jours dans
l'hémicycle pour étudier sous le regard
des Français et avec l'aide du
gouvernement les sujets du plein emploi
des droits des travailleurs en situation
de handicap et de l'organisation de la
garde d'enfants pour les travailleurs
nous aurons ainsi tout le temps
nécessaire pour confronter les opinions
et c'est bien là notre priorité et le
sens de notre présence aujourd'hui pour
suivre notre action pour atteindre le
plein emploi
en tant que député du Nord et
conseillère départemental du Nord tout
comme monsieur le rapporteur Paul
Christophe nous constatons chaque jour
les ravages du chômage vécu parfois sur
plusieurs générations et depuis 2018
depuis que le Conseil départemental
s'est activement engagé dans une
politique volontariste de retour à
l'emploi pour les bénéficiaires du RSA
nous entrevoyons enfin le bout du tunnel
grâce au partenariat noué avec l'État le
nombre de bénéficiaires du RSA est passé
de plus de 108 000 en 2018 à environ 95
000 aujourd'hui soit une baisse de 12%
et je veux saluer ici l'engagement des
agents du Département du Nord de Pôle
emploi et des partenaires qui ont permis
que désormais dans le Nord
RSA ne soit plus synonyme de désespoir
mais de réussir sans attendre il s'est
écoulé du temps avant que dans le Nord
et dans la France entière nous puissions
nous réjouir des succès que nous
enregistrons aujourd'hui sur le front de
l'emploi nous
osons déjà remis désormais parlé de
plein emploi
c'est une ambition qui nécessite encore
du coeur à l'ouvrage mais Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres nous
savons pouvoir compter sur vous vous
savez aussi pouvoir compter sur nous je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et social une motion de rejet
préalable déposée en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est donc à monsieur Adrien Clouet
pour une durée de pouvant excéder 15
minutes
[Applaudissements]
présidente collègue ministre après un
été catastrophique ou votre gestion à
privé d'eau et de médicaments des
régions entières de notre pays vous ne
trouvez pas d'autres priorités que de
terroriser toutes celles et ceux qui ont
un accident de parcours ou de vie
voilà qu'un gouvernement de millionnaire
et ses collaborateurs le pénis veulent
retirer 500 balles aux familles qui se
battent au quotidien pour survivre
manœuvre absolument détestable qui
consiste à leur faire payer vos erreurs
car ce projet n'est que l'acte 2 de
votre réforme des retraites nous vous
l'avions dit à l'époque que repousser
l'âge de départ à la retraite créerait
automatiquement des allocataires du RSA
puisque les chômeurs âgés doivent tenir
deux ans de plus sans que les droits ne
soient prorogés
nous vous l'avions dit à l'époque que
repousser l'âge de départ créerait des
travailleurs des travailleurs en
situation de handicap puisque après 60
ans plus d'un accident du travail sur 6
causes des dommages irréversibles pour
le reste de l'existence de la personne
qui lui bloque le bras le dos les jambes
ou autre et nous y voilà nous y voilà
vous savez que des dizaines de milliers
de personnes vont basculer au RSA vous
savez des dizaines de milliers de
personnes vont subir une situation de
handicap et comme d'habitude vous
réfléchissez avec 6 mois de retard
alors j'imagine qu'un ministre a dû se
dire moi qui gagnait un RSA par
demi-journée avant d'être élu je connais
bien le dossier et que vous êtes
concerté pour pondre cette idée aussi
farfelue que simpliste inscrire tout le
monde tout le monde sur la liste des
demandeuses et demandeurs d'emploi
chômeur bien sûr mais aussi personne en
situation de handicap un locataire du
RSA leur conjoint avec alors pour
l'instant vous épargnez les gosses on
est encore content jusqu'aux Invalides
même jusqu'aux Invalides même que vous
vouliez obliger à rechercher un emploi
qui ne peuvent par définition pas
occuper heureusement sur ce point on
vous a battu en commission la semaine
dernière
alors
pourquoi pourquoi inscrire tout le monde
sur la liste des demandeurs de
demandeurs d'emploi et bien pour les
obliger à signer un nouveau bout de
papier que vous avez inventé qui
s'appelle le contrat d'engagement alors
de toute façon vu que vous ne recrutez
pas d'agence supplémentaire les nouveaux
inscrits ne verront qu'un courrier dans
la boîte aux lettres ou un email puisque
aujourd'hui d'ores et déjà 20% des
allocataires du RSA n'ont pas accès à un
accompagnement en dépit des engagements
de l'État mais désormais avec votre
contrat s'il déroge à l'une des clauses
et bien pouf on leur coupe absolument
tout jusqu'au moindre euro évidemment si
l'état de son côté ne remplit pas ses
obligations ne se passera absolument
rien mais à quel moment vous êtes vous
dit qu'on est des gens en les plongeant
dans la misère c'est même une question
qui nous dépasse
si quelqu'un n'a plus un rond sur son
compte courant évidemment qui ne va pas
aller au Forum de l'Emploi évidemment
qu'elle va pas faire le plein pour aller
à Pôle Emploi évidemment qu'il ou
qu'elle ne va pas revoir ses anciens
collègues pour savoir qui on est dans le
secteur d'activité et les députés
macronistes n'ont d'ailleurs admis la
semaine dernière en commission vous avez
dit avec 500 € de RSA on ne vit pas on
survie et en dépit de ce propos vous
estimez que la survie est conditionnelle
vous nous dites des individus peuvent
être privés du droit de survivre s'il ne
répondent pas à des contrats
d'engagement donc c'est une logique
morale que nous n'acceptons pas parce
qu'un être humain a le droit de
continuer à exister quoi qu'il en soit
sans aucune condition jamais car il est
toujours notre frère ou notre sœur en
humanité quel que soit son comportement
son parcours son histoire ses proches ou
son activité
et mesurez bien la cruauté de ce que
vous faites si un demandeur ou une
demande de d'emploi rate a rendez-vous
par exemple en visio parce que la wifi
est en rade qui se trompe d'adresse pour
se rendre à une de vos formations de
qualité formation post-it ou coloriage
on sait jamais trop bref si jamais il se
trompe qu'il se qu'il commet cette
erreur on lui retire absolument tout
allocation au chômage mais aussi le RSA
qui est une allocation familiale versez
donc pour l'adulte bénéficiaire mais
aussi pour la famille et ses enfants
donc demain je traduis pour une wifi en
panne ou un GPS qui ne marche pas des
gamins ne seront plus soignés n'auront
plus le droit à des fournitures
scolaires on n'iront plus à la cantine
[Applaudissements]
alors que le droit international
interdit la notion de punition
collective vous voilà à menacer et
châtier des gamins pour les erreurs ou
accident de leurs parents c'est
j'imagine ce que la ministre berger
appelle prendre soin des enfants comme
elle l'a dit sur cette tribune il y a 5
minutes
et parlons-en même du contenu des
contreparties que vous exigez des
parents pour avoir le droit à cette
survie comme vous la qualifiez jusqu'à
15 heures par semaine d'activité
obligatoire dit autrement on va leur
bloquer 15 heures de recherche d'emploi
pour faire des ateliers gommettes ou
test de personnalité on sait jamais trop
après quoi ils vont passer les coups de
téléphone pour être recrutés quand ça la
nuit à 3h du matin ils vont appeler les
employeurs après les 15 heures
hebdomadaires obligatoires évidemment
non et bon courage les patrons pour
répondre au téléphone
d'autant que les allocataires collègues
la plupart bossent déjà d'arrache-pied
votre contrat d'engagement aura pour
conséquence essentielle de les empêcher
de continuer les activités qui nous
qu'elle conduisent aujourd'hui parce
qu'une bureaucratie aura décidé qu'elles
ne sont pas les plus légitimes hier
prenons un exemple j'étais à mon nom
ville dans ma circonscription où est
organisé une grande course sportive je
pense qu'on a tout et tous ici ce type
d'événement qui s'organise sur nos
territoires parmi les bénévoles qui
montrent les chapiteaux accompagnent les
enfants distribue le dossard il y a de
nombreuses et de nombreux allocataires
du comme ça ou des personnes en
situation de handicap et ces bénévoles
sont venus me demander quels étaient les
garanties qui nous qu'elles avaient de
pouvoir continuer à mener ce type
d'activité de pouvoir continuer à se
rendre utile à côté d'une recherche
d'emploi quel garantie de pouvoir
persister à organiser ce type
d'événement qui a une contribution à la
santé publique je leur ai dit qu'il y
avait une garantie cette motion de rejet
et son adoption
d'autant qu'au début vous nous racontiez
des salades comme quoi ces 15 heures
serviraient à découvrir des associations
faire du théâtre réussir à se découvrir
soi-même je ne sais pas quoi et mardi
dernier à 22h10 en commission monsieur
le rapporteur a vendu la messe il nous a
confirmé face caméra tout le monde
pourra vérifier que ces heures
obligatoires comprendraient des stages
des immersions en situation de travail
de la mise en poste simulée ou du
bénévolat alors vous avez inventé le
bénévolat forcé une contradiction dans
les termes on croirait entendre
macroniste de gauche et du même registre
et tout cela très cher collègue
macroniste ou le pénis je vais vous
confier un secret et bien les stages les
formations en milieu de travail la
simulation et bien c'est du travail tout
ça c'est du travail et dès lors même si
ça vous déplaît il y a encore des lois
dans ce pays qui imposent que le travail
soit rémunéré sauf que le travail Vous
vous ne l'aimez qu'à condition qu'il
soit gratuit et non payé
dès lors lorsque vous dites France
travail et bien permettez nous
d'entendre France extorsion d'autant
plus que si vous trouvez 15 heures
d'activité non payées à imposer à 7
millions de bénéficiaires et bien j'ai
une bonne nouvelle pour vous ça veut
dire que vous avez trouvé de quoi
embaucher 3 millions de gens à temps
plein sauf que là il va falloir les
payer et sortir le portefeuille
évidemment
je veux donc sonner ici l'alerte pour
toutes les salariés et tous les salariés
du pays déjà depuis un an le pouvoir
d'achat des salaires a reculé de 2% face
à ça les seuls qui n'ont aucune
obligation à l'égard de la République
sont les plus grands patrons ou les
grands actionnaires qui chaque année
détournent l'équivalent de 9 années de
RSA et eux aucun contrat d'engagement
n'est prévu pour les remettre dans le
droit chemin pour eux rien pas
d'obligation le gavage c'est offert
c'est payé maison mais demain si on
laisse faire le gouvernement les
salariés doivent bien comprendre qu'il
risque d'avoir à leur côté sur les
postes de travail des stagiaires des
personnes en formation qui ont été
placées là de manière involontaire
c'est-à-dire de force c'est un
euphémisme pour le dire et c'est une
menace pour celles et ceux qui sont mal
payées et seront mis en concurrence avec
des personnes qui exercent une activité
qui peut s'y substituer pour une
rémunération absolument nulle sur le
lieu de travail d'ailleurs les
employeurs du pays ne le demandent même
pas ils savent très bien que tout cela
va
production passer deux jours par si deux
jours par là avec des personnes qui
n'ont pas demandé à être dans ce type de
secteur ou ce type d'entreprise va créer
un jeu de bento généralisé où chacun
rêverait d'être dans la boîte d'à côté
et où personne n'ira au travail avec un
minimum de bonne humeur de motivation et
donc d'acquisition de qualification
et c'est 15h d'activité obligatoire sont
imposées il faut le rappeler à toutes et
tous les demandeurs d'emploi vous avez
fait 35 ans de boulot dans les Renault
nautiques un licenciement vous êtes
concerné par un contrat d'engagement
vous êtes agriculteur une mauvaise
récolte ou une grippe aviaire vous
passez au RSA pour le non salariés
agricoles vous êtes concerné par le
contrat d'engagement vous êtes mère
isolé
occupé à jongler avec l'emploi du temps
l'activité des enfants que vous avez à
charge vous êtes concerné vous êtes en
situation de handicap bloqué dans
certains mouvements fondamentaux de la
vie et bien vous êtes concerné alors oui
le gouvernement se gargarise d'ouvrir
aux travailleurs en situation de
handicap en ESAT des droits identiques à
tous les travailleurs et toutes les
travailleuses sauf le droit le plus
essentiel celui au salaire alors bravo
vous avez invité le salariat sans le
salaire super d'invention super bidet je
sais pas comment vous faites si c'est ça
l'idée que vous avez quand vous me
réfléchissez à 200 on n'a pas envie de
voir les petits comités bref quoi qu'il
en soit au prétexte quelqu'un travaille
en ESAT vous payez sa force de travail
deux fois moins que sur le marché du
travail extérieur ce qui est
inacceptable
[Applaudissements]
dès lors dès lors lorsque le ministre
emploie l'expression personne n'est une
employable il faut bien comprendre ce
qu'il veut dire personne n'est
inexploitable c'est bien ça l'idée
fondamentale le fil rouge de ce texte
c'est que personne ne peut être protégé
d'aller boucher les trous sur le marché
du travail pour les emplois qui sont les
plus indignes et qui ne trouvent pas
preneur ni preneuse et ce à raison
c'est pour cela c'est pour cela que vous
confiez l'orientation des personnes en
situation de handicap aux agents de
France travail plutôt comme maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
vous les confiez à des agents qui ne
sont pas formés à la condition des
personnes handicap pour vous assurer
qu'il est dirige vers des postes
inadaptés à elle et à eux ça semble
absurde oui forcément vous l'avez voté
jeudi dans la nuit à trois heures du mat
et donc dans ce texte il n'y a pas un
mot il n'y a pas un mot sur la logique
inverse tous ces postes de travail qui
produisent du handicap tous ces postes
de travail ou le déficit de protection
ou le déficit de disons les défauts de
machinerie peuvent exposer la personne à
une blessure laquelle on retourne
devient une situation de handicap pour
la forme de son existence voici la
formule de ce texte plutôt que de
protéger l'ensemble des postes de
travail pour limiter l'exposition des
blessures graves en établissant des
contraintes fortes sur le grand patronat
on met la pression sur les gens pour
qu'ils aillent n'importe quel boulot y
compris ceux qui mutile et ceux qui
handicap
évidemment évidemment comment témoigne
la grève prévue demain dans le service
public d'emploi les conseillers et
conseillères pour l'emploi n'acceptent
pas que vous les empêchez d'aider leur
public ils n'accepte pas de recevoir 3
millions de personnes en plus à effectif
constant et j'adresse d'ailleurs d'ici
au nom de mon groupe à salut fraternel à
toutes les conseillères et conseillers
Pôle emploi qui tiennent bon qui
refusent de radier les chômeurs même
lorsqu'on leur demande et qui refusent
de les forcer à accepter des offres
illégales ou indignes j'adresse
également dans le même mouvement un
salut fraternel au conseillère et
conseiller des missions locales qui sont
les véritables vigiles de la citoyenneté
sociale de notre pays qui savent bien
que d'abord il faut lever les problèmes
de santé de qualification ou d'accès aux
droits pour aider un jeune ou une jeune
à se prendre en main à diriger son
existence plutôt que lui faire signer à
la chaîne des contrats d'intérim
bref un salut à tous ces métiers qui
sont menacés par votre texte d'une
fusion laquelle va leur faire perdre
toute identité tout droit à
l'expérimentation tout droit à
l'innovation sociale et tout cela des
compétences qui disparaîtront au profit
d'un traitement en 10 minutes sur un
guichet par des agents débordés qui ne
pourront absolument plus accompagner
personne et auront comme unique recours
d'envoyer par mail des offres d'emploi
dont ils n'ont même pas vérifié la
conformité
évidemment évidemment ce sont des propos
qui ne plaisent pas forcément à une
partie de nos collègues ici présent mais
mais vous savez qu'il y avait une
manière de trancher les débats il y
avait une manière très simple de
trancher les débats c'était d'attendre
la fin de l'expérimentation
vous avez lancé une expérimentation au
début d'année cette expérimentation a
été lancée dans 18 départements alors la
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est retiré la
réunion a fait un vœu en refusant votre
programme de sanction mais enfin il y a
18 départements qui sont en cours
d'expérimentation alors on a entendu que
monsieur le ministre avait des
conclusions c'est très bien il est le
seul bravo à lui mais on aimerait bien
un pouvoir les lire et de pouvoir
s'appuyer dessus pour examiner le texte
parce que là vous avez inventé
l'expérimentation au résultat cachés
j'appelle pas ça une expérimentation
j'appelle ça une excuse c'est ça que
vous cherchez depuis le début vous
cherchez des prétextes vous avez enrôlé
des volontaires pour une expérimentation
dont les conclusions n'existent pas pour
les parlementaires que vous obligez à
voter sur quelque chose à l'aveugle bref
c'est une pratique est inadmissible pour
gagner deux semaines de débat
parlementaire vous avez transformé les
gens les allocataires les conseillères
les conseiller les usagers les usagers
en rade laboratoire et leurs échecs
leurs difficultés leur souffrance et
bien vous n'y avez apporté aucune espèce
d'intérêt vous en fichez et perduement
et c'est pourquoi refuser ce texte
aujourd'hui et maintenant c'est leur
dire que leur expérience compte que ce
qui leur est arrivé à un sens et que
nous voulons l'examiner ensemble prendre
le temps de réviser l'organisation
générale du service public d'emploi pour
le mieux 10 ans plutôt que d'avoir des
expérimentations qui sont cyniques et
veines
bref en conclusion si le texte aboutit
il n'y aura plus dans ce pays ni de
minimum de subsistance puisque vous avez
mis sous conditions le droit à la survie
ni de liberté du travail puisque vous
aurez renforcé les pressions sur les
demandeuses demandeurs d'emploi d'autant
plus que toute voix déjà pas toi a été
fermée avec la suspension massive et le
sabrage des subventions au territoire
zéro chômeurs de longue durée dans ce
cadre là
ce sera la fin de cette grande idée qui
vient en août depuis la Révolution
française selon laquelle les secours
publics sont une dette sacrée la société
doit la subsistance aux citoyens
malheureux soit en procurant du travail
soit en assurant les moyens d'exister à
celles et ceux qui sont hors d’état de
travailler et bien cette idée nous nous
la chérissons et nous savons que le seul
obstacle à sa réalisation c'est la
fortune indécente de quelques
milliardaires auxquelles jamais vous
n'imposerez de contraintes d'engagement
en dépit de ce qu'il nous coûte en
conséquence collègues rejetons ce texte
alors je vous remercie je vous indique
sur le vote de la motion de rejet
préalable je suis saisie par le groupe
la France insoumise et le groupe
socialiste et apparenté d'une demande de
scrutin public qui est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
alors donc j'ai plusieurs explications
de votes sur cette notion la première
Monsieur François Gernigon vous avez la
parole oui merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues la France insoumise
dépose une motion de rejet concernant un
texte qui vise l'ambition noble du plein
emploi
depuis 2017 sous la bannière de cette
majorité nous avons œuvré pour réduire
le chômage et dynamiser notre économie
les résultats parlent de même le taux de
chômage est au plus bas depuis plus de
40 ans et le taux d'emploi au plus haut
avec plus de 1,7 millions d'emplois
créés depuis 2017
ces réussites ne doivent pas nous faire
oublier la nécessité d'aller plus loin
de renforcer nos dispositifs pour que
chaque citoyen trouve sa place sur le
marché du travail
alors le groupe horizon ne serait
soutenir cette motion de rejet qu'un
nous croyons en ce projet de loi qui est
l'incarnation de nos efforts incessants
et de notre volonté indéfectible
d'offrir à chaque citoyen une chance
égale sur le marché du travail et un
service public de l'emploi de qualité
quand nous entreprises rencontrent des
difficultés de recrutement et plus de 2
millions de personnes touchent le RSA
pour une majorité d'entre eux depuis
plusieurs années
alors oui nous assumons de proposer un
contrat d'engagement avec des droits et
des devoirs renforcer pour un
accompagnement plus important et plus
personnalisé en fonction des besoins
c'est pour cela que nous avons pu
adopter en commission lors de nos débats
un amendement précisant que la durée
minimale de 15 heures d'activité pour
les bénéficiaires du RSA s'appliquera
seulement si cela s'avère adapté à la
situation particulière de demandeur
d'emploi et aux difficultés qu'il
rencontre
personnellement je regrette que depuis
le début certains ici semblent choisir
l'opposition systématique plutôt que le
soutien à des politiques qui
manifestement portent leurs fruits
et il est je pense
utile de rappeler à la nupes que
s'opposer pour s'opposer n'est pas une
vision c'est simplement une impasse
alors le groupe horizon votre acompte
cette motion et restera fidèle à sa
mission celle de servir les Français
[Applaudissements]
alors vous allez avoir le micro attendez
c'est voilà c'est la raison merci madame
la Présidente le groupe écologiste votre
bien sûr cette motion de rejet
finalement avec ce projet de loi c'est
la traque au précaire qui continue vous
nous proposez un nouveau texte basé sur
la sanction comme si les chômeurs
étaient de leur plein gré bah oui
puisque c'est le plein d'emploi et il y
a des métiers en tension donc c'est
logique il y a dans notre pays plus de 5
millions de chômeurs et 300 000 emplois
disponibles comment pouvez-vous parler
de pleine emploi vous nous vendez un
projet d'organisation renouvelé du
service public de l'emploi pour
accompagner au plus près les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi mais il n'en est
rien en réalité vous assumez ici un
projet de rationalisation des moyens la
preuve votre première version du budget
pour 2024 sur le site de Bercy annonce
un nombre d'agents pour Pôle Emploi
identique à l'année précédente alors
pour des prest privée on sait ce que ça
a donné pour d'autres services publics
le recours au privé et notamment je
pense à la formation professionnelle
quand tout c'est tout ou nous faisions
démarcher sans arrêt pour nous faire
vendre pour notre compte professionnel
formation du développement personnel du
permis de conduire ou je ne sais quoi
encore non ce n'est pas cela un bon
service public de l'emploi alors vous
parlez de quelques centaines de millions
d'euros que vous mettrez au pot mais en
réalité ce n'est pas vous qui les
mettrez au pot ce seront les chômeurs et
les chômeuses qui par la restriction des
allocations chômage permettent à
l'unédicte de dégager de nouveaux
budgets aujourd'hui ce que vous nous
proposez ce n'est pas un investissement
de la solidarité nationale pour financer
un magnifique service public de l'emploi
c'est le fait de retirer au demandeur et
aux demandeuses d'emploi des allocations
grâce à votre loi précédent de l'année
dernière pour payer le service public de
l'emploi qui va les sanctionner a
vraiment je vous félicite c'est
extrêmement malin et c'est plein de
cynisme je terminerai en disant que
est-ce la loi pleine emploi non c'est la
loi bas salaire car vous refusez aux
salariés la capacité de négocier or en
raison des sanctions que vous allez
imposer aux demandeurs et demandeurs si
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Pierre Daredevil
merci madame la Présidente ce texte à
nos yeux est un nouveau texte de guerre
sociale après celui sur les retraites
après les multiples entailles au code du
travail que vous avez organisé depuis
que vous êtes au pouvoir oui il faut
lutter contre le chômage mais il ne faut
pas lutter contre les chômeurs et les
chômeuses il y a
365700 offres d'emploi vacances au
deuxième trimestre 2023 selon la Dares
et 5,4 millions de chômeurs selon Pôle
Emploi donc vous voyez bien qu'il ne
suffit pas de traverser la rue comme ça
a été dit par le Président de la
République or c'est de cette logique là
que vous êtes en train de mettre en
oeuvre une logique adéquationniste oui
il faut mieux accompagner les personnes
privées d'emploi et cela ne se règle pas
par l'injonction et la punition en
réalité ce qui est en train de se passer
ce que vous voulez faire c'est porter
atteinte à nouveau encore à la qualité
de l'emploi et au niveau des salaires
c'est enlever ce que les salariés ont pu
gagner de rapports de force dans la
période et ce qui a pu légèrement se
rééquilibrer en leur faveur et en
réalité vous mélangez tout vous mélangez
la protection sociale et la solidarité
nationale vous mélangez la location
chômage et le RSA vous mélangez le
public et le privé dans le nouveau Grand
Tout que vous êtes en train d'organiser
évidemment en ouvrant de nouveaux
espaces au marché vous allez piocher au
passage dans les caisses de lunédique
vous allez modifier l'émission des
agents et en définitive les
expérimentations que vous aviez commencé
à conduire nous n'en savons rien que ce
qui vous arrange et donc vous mettez la
charrue avant les boeufs et vous décidez
de déposer cette loi avant même que nous
sachions de quoi il retourne enfin je
terminerai en vous disant que votre loi
n'est pas prête aussi parce que vous ne
n'écrivez rien sur l'outre-mer
simplement vous vous autorisez à
légiférer tout seul sur le sujet et
c'est inacceptable
si la parole est maintenant à Madame
Michel perron
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues depuis six ans notre majorité
agit pour réconcilier les Français avec
la valeur travail le taux de chômage n'a
jamais été à son plus bas niveau depuis
1982 en 2017
9,4% en 2023 7,2 % baisse de plus de 2
points concrètement un million 700 000
emplois ont été créés dans notre pays
sur le précédent quinquennat ce projet
de loi pose un cadre pour permettre une
amélioration de l'offre de service
proposée aux personnes en recherche
d'emploi à travers votre motion de rejet
vous refusez le renforcement de
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et des bénéficiaires du RSA vous refusez
la mise en place d'un contrat
d'engagement qui a déjà fait ses preuves
auprès des jeunes vous dites non à un
accompagnement individuel et intensif
pour une entrée rapide et durable dans
l'emploi Vous refusez une meilleure
population de tous les acteurs de
l'emploi les collectivités les
opérateurs les acteurs de l'insertion au
service des usagers et des entreprises à
travers cette notion de rejet Vous vous
opposez à la création du service public
de la petite enfance nous le savons la
garde d'enfants est un des freins
périphériques principaux pour l'emploi
notamment pour les femmes comment
pouvez-vous vous y opposer enfin vous
allez contester de nouveaux droits pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
ce texte favorise leur accès à l'emploi
en simplifiant la RQTH et fait converger
les droits des travailleurs en ESAT avec
ceux des salariés si l'on vous écoute on
ne devrait rien changer tout va bien
vous ne proposez rien nous portons des
mesures structurantes et fondatrices
d'un nouveau modèle pour le plein emploi
notre groupe s'opposera évidemment à
cette motion de rejet madame la
Présidente je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Victor Catteau
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de commission mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues ce texte est censé traiter de
la problématique de l'emploi dans notre
pays il est pourtant clair qu'il s'était
garé de son objectif initial notre pays
connu une situation sociale extrêmement
tendue les Français subissent au
quotidien l'inflation la perte
progressive de leur pouvoir d'achat mais
aussi la montée de la violence et
d'insécurité il n'est pas qu'on se
valable monsieur le ministre dans un tel
contexte de demander à celles et ceux
qui vivent déjà avec presque rien de
faire encore plus d'efforts il n'est pas
concevable de demander aux personnes en
situation de handicap au proche aidant
et aux parents isolés de faire
abstraction de leur situation et de
leurs obligations pour faire encore plus
d'efforts il n'est pas convenable
monsieur le ministre de demander à
celles et ceux qui ont travaillé qui ont
cotisé et qui ont obtenu des droits
d'abandonner ses droits de les
conditionner à un contrat d'agrange
d'engagement irréalisable et de faire
encore plus d'efforts il n'est pas
concevable monsieur le ministre
d'appeler un projet de loi pleine emploi
lorsque vous excluez les jeunes de ce
texte que vous accordez des miettes
travailler handicapés et aux
professionnels de la petite enfance il
n'est pas convenable monsieur le
ministre près d'un an après la réforme
des retraites de ne pas inclure les
seigneurs dans ce projet
votre chance d'agir pour nos aînés
étaient là et vous ne l'avez pas saisi
votre texte n'est qu'un camouflé qui
vise une nouvelle fois au prix mais un
peu plus nos concitoyens les moins
fortunés à rogner nos droits et à qui
sociaux et qui montre à nouveau le
véritable visage hypocrite de la
macronie cette macronie qui se fiche de
la vie des Français qui se fichent de
savoir si ces derniers pourront terminer
la semaine tant qu'ils continuent de
travailler même dans les pires
conditions pour autant nous
reconnaissons la nécessité absolue de
légiférer sur ce sujet le plein emploi
est un objectif de que tout gouvernement
se doit de poursuivre dans la série de
nos concitoyens c'est pourquoi il nous
apparaît essentiel de débattre de ce
texte dans cette hémicycle de faire
valoir nos positions de faire valoir nos
idées par le débat par le vote et non
par le rejet je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Jean-Hugues
oui madame la Présidente ministre ce
projet de loi démonte encore une fois
que vous n'aimez pas les pauvres
l'époque que vous accusez de tous les
mots de la société pourquoi les traiter
vous comme des parias que
où placez-vous l'humain dans votre
politique nulle part et là que ce soit
les demandeurs d'emploi ou les
bénéficiaires du FSA vous pensez
sincèrement qui sont contents de leur
situation vous croyez vraiment que c'est
un plaisir pour eux de ne pas se nourrir
correctement de ne pas pouvoir se
soigner dignement de ne pas avoir des
petits loisirs pour eux pour comme pour
leurs enfants ce texte est immoral
honteux comment
osez-vous agiter le fouet contre ceux
qui ont peu
où est la solidarité où est la liberté
où est l'égalité où est la fraternité un
texte qui menace de supprimer les
allocations si le bénéficiaire reste
un seul rendez-vous une un texte qui
porte une attaque très grave sans
précédent contre le salariat un texte
qui flippe toute la famille on oublie
Jean les concubines et concubins des
bénéficiaires du SA à s'inscrit à Pôle
Emploi même les handicapés handicapés ne
trouvent pas grâce à vos yeux c'est
lamentable vous vous prétendez vouloir
faire faire du plein emploi mais dans le
même temps vous annoncez la suppression
de 15000 contrats aidés l'année
prochaine sans oublier la remise en
cause du territoire euro chômeur quelle
hypocrisie les conséquences de votre
projet de loi vont être terribles ici
dans l'Hexagone et vont être
catastrophiques inhumain dans les
outre-mer enfin vous voulez traiter les
outre-mer pas de parodonnance pour
appliquer ce projet de loi si les voté
nous vous disons très fermement non nous
ne voulons pas désordonnances votre ex
est dangereux monsieur le ministre c'est
pour tous ces raisons et l'exposer
humain très humain de mon collègue cloué
que nous pouvons pour cette motion de
rejet remercie la parole est maintenant
à Monsieur Philippe Juvin
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ce Clouet la situation sur le plan du
chômage
n'est pas bonne elle est très mauvaise
nous sommes 25e 23e sur 25 dans l'Union
européenne donc nous ne sommes pas
parmi les mauvais élèves nous sommes des
mauvaises élèves et vous vous nous dites
et vous vous nous dites surtout tout va
mal mais on débat de rien
mais comment voulez-vous que chose
change monsieur Clouet un député il est
payé pourquoi il est payé pour que la
loi améliore les conditions de vie des
Français vous nous dites tout va mal
mais surtout mesdames et messieurs
rentrez chez vous ne discutez pas c'est
inaudible alors nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur le fond pas d'accord du
tout nous l'avons vu la semaine dernière
là en commission des affaires sociales
vous vous considérez que le RSA c'est un
droit inconditionnel nous croyons
absolument l'inverse
nous pensons qu'en face du RSA il doit y
avoir des contreparties mais c'est un
sujet
important passionnant et vous voulez
l'évacuer on ne discutant pas alors
Monsieur Clouet prenez le risque du
débat c'est la démocratie et vous verrez
ça fait du bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous considérez que mieux accompagner
les 1,9 millions de foyers bénéficiaires
du RSA vers un parcours social
socioprofessionnel professionnel ou une
formation n'est pas une avancée vous
considérez qu'améliorer le service
public de la petite enfance pour
notamment aider les 160 000 femmes
empêcher de chercher un emploi faute de
solutions de garde n'est pas une avancée
vous considérez enfin que mieux
accompagner reconnaître la qualité de
travailleurs handicapé et ses
spécificités ainsi que les droits des
milliers de personnes travaillant en
ESAT n'est pas une avancée en somme vous
considérez que tout va bien et qu'il est
urgent de ne rien changer ne rien faire
pour les demandes en emploi voici votre
programme j'ai assisté à toutes les
auditions à toutes les auditions et j'ai
pu constater que la quasi intégralité
des acteurs de l'emploi étaient
favorables à ce PGL il y a eu des
suggestions d'amélioration évidemment
certaines ont été satisfaites par des
amendements acceptés en commission
qu'elles viennent de la majorité ou de
l'opposition et d'autres pourraient
intervenir dans le cadre de la séance
nous croyons nous démocrates
fondamentalement que le travail est
source d'émancipation d'insertion de
réinsertion et
œuvre à la réduction de la pauvreté
notre groupe votre rat contre cette
motion de rejet préalable je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole et maintenant
à Monsieur Arthur de la porte s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues est-ce que
vous voulez bien entrer
discrètement dans les hémicycles pour
que monsieur delaport puisse exprimer
dans de bonnes conditions
vous avez la parole chers collègues
merci madame la Présidente ce texte sur
le plein emploi et bien loin d'être
plein il s'organise autour d'un grand
vide de sens vite de moyens vide de tout
ce qui manquerait pour réparer notre
contrat social abîmé par vos réformes
successives celle de l'assurance chômage
celle des retraites ce texte il est mal
fils et il est bakelé vous osez tout de
même le présenter ici sans études
d'impact sans aucune analyse finalement
du rôle des sanctions rien non plus sur
l'impact sur l'égalité famome quand les
femmes sont les allocataires du RSA les
plus pauvres aucun retour sur les
expérimentations bref s'il vous plaît
votre ambasserie ce sont aussi les
changements de pieds permanents un jour
ça s'appelle France travail le lendemain
ça s'appelle Pôle emploi
le lendemain ça se rappelle France
travail et puis finalement France
travaille devient le rail le réseau des
acteurs de l'insertion et de l'emploi
curieuse termine au jeu mais finalement
Pôle Emploi devient france-travail bref
comprenne qui pourra on en finit surtout
avec l'insertion et l'inscription
automatique et forcée des allocataires
du RSA comme des demandeurs d'emploi
vous inscrivez même ceux qui ne peuvent
pas travailler vous inscrivez même les
conjoints qui travaillent déjà comment
se satisfaire d'un texte ou les sujets
majeurs le handicap la petite enfance se
trouve inséré fortuitement alors qu'ils
auraient mérité de plus grandes
ambitions et de véritables débats et de
véritables textes nous en aurions
volontiers discuter en commission si ce
texte n'avait pas été adopté aux forces
en catimini et au milieu de la nuit
à aucun moment ce texte ne pose des
sujets qui font qu'on ne retrouve pas un
emploi niveau de rémunération qualité
pénibilité de l'emploi à aucun moment il
ne considère véritablement et
sérieusement les freins périphériques
mobilité par exemple depuis que nous
avons depuis que nous avons chiffré
votre projet à 10 milliards d'euros
jamais nous avons été contredis ces
milliards nécessaires ils sont pourtant
absents cessons là la plaisanterie car
elle est tragique votons cette notion de
rejet
je vais donc mettre au bois la motion de
rejet préalable
merci de regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]
le scrutin est fermé
[Applaudissements]
donc votant 229 exprimés 210 majorités
106 pour 62 contre 149 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a donc pas adopté cette
motion de rejet préalable en conséquence
le projet de loi est rejeté il n'y aura
pas lieu de procédés au vote solennelle
voilà je vous remercie et nous en
arrivons donc à la discussion générale
merci de quitter les mystiques
en silence chers collègues
et donc la parole
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur François
Gernigon
vous avez la parole chers collègues et
merci de faire un peu de silence je vous
remercie
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce rapporteur chers collègues
depuis 2017 l'ambition claire est
résolue de notre majorité a été la
priorité donnée à la politique de
l'emploi aujourd'hui il nous est
présenté un projet de loi audacieux qui
s'inscrit dans une vision à long terme
pour un meilleur service public de
l'emploi pour tous un dialogue et un
accompagnement renforcé et une confiance
en nos collectivités territoriales
précisées
regardons les chiffres notre taux de
chômage n'a jamais été aussi bas depuis
40 ans au deuxième trimestre 2023 il est
porté à 7,2% de la population active et
1,7 millions d'emplois ont été créés
depuis 2017 amenant notre taux d'emploi
au plus haut depuis qu'il est mesuré par
l'INSEE
cette dynamique est le fruit de
nombreuses réformes de nombreux textes
ambitieux
cette tendance à la baisse et
particulièrement notable chez nos jeunes
montrant que cette vision d'un marché de
travail dynamique n'est pas un simple
idéal mais une réalité en construction
avec pour objectif le plein emploi d'ici
le rapport de préfiguration de France
travail nous a été présenté nous a
présenté un tableau qui bien que
réaliste nous interpelle
il mentionne des accompagnements peu
intensifs de suivi tardif voire plus
formel coréenne et évoque des actions
peu tournées vers l'emploi ou
l'entreprise
illustre également à quel point le
parcours peuvent être éclatés et
manquait cruellement de coordination
les entreprises peinent à recruter 18%
des allocataires du RSA ne sont suivies
par aucun organisme ce sont ces constats
qui poussent à l'action
c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi au-delà
des chiffres vise une transformation
profonde avec comme ambition de
renforcer l'accompagnement vers l'emploi
de chacun et chacune tout
particulièrement de ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés du monde professionnel
cet accompagnement se doit d'être plus
efficace plus engible plus personnalisé
en facilitant leur parcours
avec la création de cette bannière
commune importante que France travail
sera rendu automatique l'inscription de
toutes les personnes sans emploi dont
les allocataires du RSA et les
bénéficiaires d'un accompagnement de Cap
emploi et des missions locales
au-delà de cette simplicité l'enjeu
premier est de garantir un suivi adapté
et continue pour chaque individu de même
de manière coordonnée
le contrat d'engagement unique vient
remplacer la mosaïque actuelle
clarifiant ainsi les droits et devoirs
de chacun
sur ce sujet nous soutiendrons
l'introduction d'une clause pour les 15
heures d'activité des bénéficiaires du
RSA
s'assurant que cela soit adapté à leurs
besoins et difficultés
le texte porte également un ensemble de
mesures pour les travailleurs en
situation de handicap
l'orthodoxe est actuellement au plus bas
depuis 8 ans s'établissant à 12% en 2022
c'est une avancée notable
particulièrement en comparaison du taux
de chômage global qui est passé de 8% à
7% entre juin 2021 et juin 2022
mais nous pouvons et nous devons faire
mieux c'est pour cette raison que ce
projet de loi visait également à
renforcer notre dispositif
le titre 3 et ces articles sont
spécifiquement consacrés à faciliter
l'insertion professionnelle des
travailleurs handicapés
en outre avec ce texte en consolidant le
rôle des missions locales au sein du
réseau France travail nous reconnaissons
et amplifions le rôle crucial
elles sont en première ligne pour
accompagner nos jeunes nécessitant un
soutien socio-professionnel
il est désormais précisé dans le texte
que tous les jeunes suivis par les
missions locales ne sont pas en attente
d'un accompagnement professionnel et non
pas tous vocation à être inscrit à Pôle
emploi suite à l'examen en affaires
sociales
enfin
pour éliminer les obstacles
périphériques à l'emploi le texte
établit le service public d'accueil des
jeunes enfants en définissant sa gestion
et son application à l'échelle
territoriale il attribue également aux
communes la responsabilité de cet
accueil est modernise et intensifie le
contrôle des crèches qu'elle soit
publique ou privée
chaque mesure est un reflet de notre
engagement à poursuivre notre objectif
du plein emploi avec ce texte mais
également avec d'autres qui suivront je
pense notamment en travaillant en cours
avec les partenaires sociaux sur
l'emploi des seniors qui sera un autre
point capital pour arriver aux objectifs
ambitieux fixés
le groupe horizon et apparenté
soutiendra évidemment ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie
et maintenant à Madame Marie-Charlotte
Garin
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur et Madame
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente de commission chers
collègues pour préparer ce texte sur le
plein d'emploi j'ai lancé un appel à
témoignage j'en ai reçu des dizaines et
des dizaines en quelques jours comme
nous en recevons tous et toutes au cours
de notre mandat j'ai décidé aujourd'hui
d'attirer votre attention notamment sur
deux d'entre eux car je trouve qu'ils
sont plus parlants que certains discours
il y a eu Emma d'abord qui m'a écrit je
suis au rsa depuis quelques années ma
situation personnelle rend difficile mon
retour à l'emploi car je suis maman solo
à 100%, mon enfant n'a pas de deuxième
parent je n'ai pas de famille et de
relais gratuit à proximité mon enfant a
fait une phobie scolaire en 2021 et j'ai
dû la déscolariser car il était en
grande souffrance je suis donc H24 avec
elle avant de commencer l'instruction en
famille j'ai bien essayé de postuler à
des annonces d'offres d'emploi mais en
étant maman solo sans relais c'était
compliqué les employeurs n'étaient pas
intéressés par mon profil trop
contraignant
pourtant j'étais vraiment motivée le RSA
permet de survivre mais on doit sauter
des repas personne ne reste au RSA par
confort aujourd'hui avec l'instruction
en famille mon enfant va mieux
heureusement je me suis tournée vers le
statut d'auto-entrepreneur en
télétravail pour pouvoir assumer toutes
mes responsabilités mais cela prend du
temps je m'occupe de mon enfant toute la
journée je fais son instruction du mieux
possible et je m'occupe de mon projet
professionnel le soir quand elle dort et
le matin avant qu'elle se réveille moi
je dors peu
il y a Victor aussi qui m'écrit il dit
j'ai travaillé pendant trois ans à
travailler et apprendre ensemble
l'entreprise qui a servi de laboratoire
au territoire zéro chômeurs deux ans
comme peintre en bâtiment et un an comme
homme de ménage et cuisinier je pense
que l'emploi ça ne suffit pas les
collègues avaient un emploi garanti dans
une entreprise faite pour s'adapter à
leurs conditions et ça n'a fait que
ralentir la chute personne n'en sort par
le haut la plupart en fait quitte
l'entreprise avant la retraite
en décédant
il ne faut pas juste penser à l'emploi
mais aussi au reste à l'entourage au
soutien psy au logement parce que quand
tu vis dans un logement squaté ou chez
Antibes qui t'héberge pour des motifs
louches comment tu fais pour gérer un
boulot quand et merci célibataire de
trois enfants et que tu parles mal
français quand tu fais de l'arthrose à
55 ans mais que tu as bossé pour ton
mari tenancier de barre qui déclarait
pas ton salaire pendant 20 ans quand
est-ce schizophrène et que je suis seul
avec ton père que tu prends plus ou
moins tes médocs que tu te mets à parler
au mur et insulter l'air qui va leur
donner à ces gens là le plein emploi un
emploi qu'il soit capable de tenir et
dont il puisse se sentir fier
monsieur le ministre au fond votre
projet de loi il me met mal à l'aise
d'abord parce qu'il fait porter toute la
responsabilité de leurs conditions de
vie à ces gens qu'il suffit de les
fréquenter un après-midi pour se rendre
compte de la situation inextricable dans
laquelle il et elle se trouve augmenter
les contraintes sur eux ne fait que
renforcer la peur et la stigmatisation
on l'a dit les personnes ont avant tout
besoin d'un accompagnement bienveillant
de proximité avec quelqu'un qui est du
temps alors consacré aujourd'hui les
conseillers Pôle Emploi gèrent parfois
plus de 100 demandeurs d'emploi nous
travailleur sociaux aujourd'hui Monsieur
le Ministre ils n'ont pas les moyens de
vos ambitions
par ailleurs c'est la responsabilité de
l'État de faire en sorte que les plus
vulnérables puissent accéder à leurs
droits ça fait 6 ans ça fait 6 ans que
tous les ans vous nous promettez
d'avancer sur la question du non recours
au minima sociaux et on attend toujours
c'est aussi la responsabilité des
entreprises de s'adapter de proposer de
meilleures conditions de travail avec
l'aide de l'État cancer nécessaire
pourquoi est-ce que certains secteurs ne
trouvent plus de candidats est-ce qu'il
faut y orienter les travailleurs de
force est-ce que vous vous seriez prêt à
orienter vos fils et vos filles
réfléchissez-y parce que dans ce texte
encore une fois on ne trouve aucune
aucune exigence pour les entreprises
c'est enfin la responsabilité des femmes
et des hommes politiques d'anticiper
l'avenir d'encourager le développement
de certains métiers au détriment
d'autres parce que oui la raréfaction
des ressources la multiplication des
événements climatiques extrêmes la
hausse des températures vont
profondément modifier nos façons de
vivre et donc nos façons de travailler
il va nous falloir rapidement adapter
notre législation et notre modèle social
mieux protéger les gens au travail
pensez la semaine de quatre jours le
revenu de base des tas de régions en
Europe dont des régions françaises font
des expérimentations vous devriez les
soutenir et les développer plutôt que de
vous enfermer dans un vieux modèle
productiviste selon lequel tous ceux qui
ne produit pas ne cotisent pas ne
consomme pas n'a pas de valeur j'ai
nommé les jeunes les aînés les chômeurs
alors oui puisque vous vous êtes la
start-up nation ayez le courage
d'innover et je conclurai sur les mots
d'un dernier témoignage celui de Laura
tout le monde fait semblant de ne pas
constater laustrialisation comme cause
première de la baisse des emplois
disponibles
l'individu sans emploi est alors blâmé
et c'est un sentiment de honte qui
émerge avant je reprenais l'expression
d'une amie qui disait vivement la
retraite mais ça c'était avant
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant monsieur Yannick Monet
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la Présidente
mesdames monsieur le ministre
mais madame monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
dans ce projet de loi que de préjugés
que de stigmatisation vis-à-vis des
demandeurs d'emploi des personnes au RSA
qui profiteraient de la solidarité
nationale qui ne voudrait pas travailler
alors qu'il suffit de traverser la rue
pour trouver un emploi de quoi justifier
une attaque sans précédent contre le
travail en effet avec votre projet de
loi le travail n'est plus un outil qui
contribue à l'épanouissement individuel
pour faire société mais bien une
contrainte devant répondre aux seuls
besoin économiques du marché
à votre société du plein d'emploi les
députés communistes c'est ultramarins
oppose une société du travail avec de
bons emplois
pour commencer sachez qu'être privée
d'emploi est toujours un drame qui
engendre de très nombreuses difficultés
durables notamment en matière de vie
familiale et de santé personne ne s'en
réjouit
c'est vrai nous rencontrons
régulièrement dans nos permanences des
employeurs qui ne trouvent pas de main
d'oeuvre mais nous rencontrons tout
aussi souvent des demandeurs d'emploi
qui cherchent du travail mais n'en
trouve pas car il faut partir d'un
diagnostic honnête sur l'état de
l'emploi et du chômage dans notre pays
et comme ça a été rappelé plusieurs fois
selon les chiffres de Pôle emploi plus
de 5 millions de personnes privées
d'emplois dont 3 millions en catégories
A selon la Dares il y a
367.500 emplois Wacken il y a donc 8
fois plus de demandeurs d'emploi de
catégorie que d'emploi disponibles et
ces emplois sont aussi bien des CDI que
des CDD ou encore des emplois
saisonniers de plus vous parlez de plein
emploi mais rien aucune proposition pour
la création d'emploi de qualité vous
pouvez toujours vous réjouir de la
baisse du chômage comme cet effet par le
ministre tout à l'heure mais encore
faut-il que les retours à l'emploi
soient réels et de qualité or vous ne
dites jamais que la baisse toute
relative du chômage est celle de
l'augmentation sans précédent de retour
à l'emploi en contrat très précaire en
un an plus 26 de contrats de moins de 20
heures et une sortie sur 10 des chiffres
du chômage et désormais dû à une
radiation votre projet de loi vise
précisément accentuer ses tendances
c'est un projet de plein de mauvaise
emploi par ailleurs si nous pouvons
souscrire au fait qu'il faille sans
aucun doute clarifier des circuits
rendre plus accessible et plus
performant le service public de l'emploi
votre projet de réforme ne va pas dans
ce sens d'abord parce que la description
de l'entité France travaille de ces
comités à tous les échelons territoriaux
de son réseau associant tous les
organismes d'accompagnement le public
comme le privé sans plus de distinction
états est assez difficile à appréhender
jusqu'à ce que l'on comprenne que le
comité national président aux grandes
orientations se rentrent les seuls mains
de votre ministère cette concentration
du pouvoir laisse perplexe sur le projet
politique et la marge de manœuvre des
différents opérateurs publics de
l'insertion et de l'emploi ainsi
faites-vous le choix d'en finir avec
Pôle Emploi si Pôle Emploi devient
France travail ce pas anodin la notion
de travail plus vaste introduit l'idée
qu'il faut être en activité sous peine
d'être identifié à un noisif à l'image
de la réforme du resa qui conditionne
son versement à 15 heures d'activité par
semaine sans préciser la nature même de
cette activité ce faisant vous remettez
en cause frontalement nos principes de
solidarité et vous transformer le RSA en
une allocation de retour à l'emploi
quand il est une allocation de
subsistance vous entretenez la confusion
entre l'allocation chômage et le RSA
entre le revenu de remplacement
assurantiel et la prestation sociale
assise sur la solidarité et financé par
l'impôt pour à terme supprimer l'une ou
l'autre
avec votre projet de loi tout le monde
devient un inscrit sur la liste des
demandeurs d'emploi jusqu'au conjoint ou
concubin d'un locataire du RSA et même
dans votre texte initial était prévu des
personnes à valides tout le monde est
soumis au même contrat d'engagement et
surtout de menaces de sanctions plus
fortes et Pôle emploi rebaptisé France
travail devient une sorte de gare de
triage enfin si véritablement vous
escomptez un meilleur accompagnement sur
mesure de chacun il faut des moyens dans
l'étude d'impact nous sommes renvoyés au
PLF de 2024 et puis en parallèle il y a
la lettre de cadrage d'une rare violence
adressée aux organisations syndicales et
patronales dans le cadre de l'actuel
négociation d'une indique où l'on
découvre que c'est l'unedique qui doit
devenir l'un des contributeurs majeurs
de votre réforme sans que les députés
leur mot à dire
il y a un grave problème sur ce choix de
financement un mélange des genres un
détournement d'argent public normalement
destiné à l'assurantielle les
organisations ne s'y sont pas trompées
elles ont unanimement refusé vos
orientations pour finir sachez-le ce ne
sont pas les dispositions relatives à
l'accueil de la petite enfance dont nous
n'avons plus débattre en commission qui
détournent l'auront le regard des
députés communistes et ultramarins des
enjeux dévastateurs de ce texte je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Arthur de la porte
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
ce ministre mesdames et messieurs des
ministres chers collègues
d'expérience oui demander des aides
sociales c'est ressentir le poids du
jugement des autres
le fait de se sentir assisté voire
parasite comme beaucoup le pense et le
vent de certains médias
plus facile et économique de
culpabiliser et punir que d'accompagner
dignement des citoyens dans une passe
difficile
témoignage de pierre
reçu ce week-end et lumineux de vérité
en renforçant et en accent autour des
sanctions contrat d'engagement
prétendument réciproque le mot
réciproque étant par ailleurs un ajout
obtenu par les députés de gauche à aucun
moment vous ne réconcilier ici l'emploi
et la solidarité que l'étape doit
pourtant à celles et ceux qui en sont
éloignés
j'ai à ma droite un formulaire
c'est celui que les comptables des
entreprises doivent remplir chaque année
pour obtenir des réductions de déficit
et de crédits d'impôts ça fait deux
pages
ces aides elles coûtent chaque année des
dizaines de milliards d'euros à l'État
et elles sont versées sans condition
j'ai ici à ma gauche un formulaire de
demande de RSA alors celui-là il fait 7
pages
puis il doit être rempli tous les trois
mois il doit être rempli tous les trois
mois et ces aides là elles sont
conditionnées sous peine de devoir
rembourser le trop-perçu ou d'être
catalogue comme fraudeur il faut sans
cesse mettre à jour ces informations
puis on n'a pas le droit de se tromper
ici on comptabilise toutes les
ressources un même le moindre revenu
même la moindre allocation tout ça pour
se recevoir au mieux 607 euros quand on
a une personne seule ou 1093 euros donc
pour un couple avec enfants
est-ce déséquilibré c'est à vous de me
dire où est-ce déjà trop finalement pour
ceux qui n'ont rien c'est en tout cas et
objectivement pour le RSA revenu en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté monétaire
et qui décroche de plus en plus par
rapport au SMIC
607 euros par mois au maximum c'est trop
peu pour maintenir légèrement la tête
hors de l'autre on peut pour échapper à
la très grande pauvreté trop peu pour
survivre dignement
cette page fastidieuse donc 30% des
allocataires qui n'ont pas recours cette
page derrière lesquelles finalement ce
cache un contrôle déjà très présent je
l'ai dit une absence à un rendez-vous un
déménagement non signalé c'est la mise à
l'amende 50 80 100% du montant en moins
et puis la radiation au bout du chemin
pour vous c'est cette page c'est la
philosophie de la sanction celle que
vous les renforcer démultiplier c'est
finalement celle du café du commerce qui
voit les pauvres comme des assistés ou
les paresseux qui transparaissaient
d'ailleurs dans le témoignage que je
cité tout à l'heure
la location n'est-elle après tout par la
réponse des lâches c'est finalement ce
que suggérer Christophe Castaner peu
importe l'inefficacité prouvé des
sanctions peu importe les enfants qui
trinquons parce que leurs parents auront
été vu comme défaillants peu importe les
conjoints qu'on inscrira demain de force
à Pôle emploi et même s'ils ont déjà un
travail il y a bien une philosophie
commune à ce texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui et celle du texte nous
éliminions il y a un an c'était
l'assurance chômage tout est fait pour
créer un droit complexe un droit
illisible un droit finalement comme il
est lisible qui ne peut avoir d'effet
incitatifs ou des incitatifs un droit
complexe une belle usine à gaz cela va
surtout comme le montre toutes les
études créer du non recours au droit en
pointant du doigt les plus écorchés vous
installez peu à peu votre idéologie
néolibérale
celle qui désencage toujours un peu plus
l'état
nous aurions pourtant pu saisir
l'occasion de ce texte pour renouer avec
l'histoire celle de notre protection
sociale celle de l'État providence en
réengageant l'État dans des dépenses
d'insertion pour garantir un revenu
minimum d'existence
inconditionnel versez automatiquement
vous préférez donc la mise sous contrôle
les élocataires que nous vous ne voyez
que les travailleurs en puissance à tout
le mieux et sinon comme des fraudeurs
paresseux qui pénalisent la société
cette logique c'est la terrible logique
du Walter c'est celle qui a été mise en
place au Royaume Uni celle qui conduit
derrière par la privatisation et la
déshumanisation du service de l'emploi à
produire des Daniel Blake en série vous
savez c'est ce héros du film éponyme de
Ken Loach qui montre finalement les
ravages kafkaïens de la transformation
malheureuse du service public de
l'emploi votre projet sur
l'accompagnement que vous essayez
d'opposer en miroir est aussi creux
finalement que votre tâche trajectoire
budgétaire est impressionniste et
insuffisante à aucun moment vous
n'évoquez les effectifs et les moyens
nécessaires l'accompagnement le retour à
l'emploi c'est donc un mythe que vous
entretenez pour faire reposer sur les
collectivités locales infinie le coût de
votre irresponsabilité tout en ayant
réussi l'exploit de pressuriser les
agents de Pôle emploi avec ce texte donc
vous créez toujours plus de pauvreté une
société où l'emploi lui-même ne protège
plus contre la pauvreté avec ce texte
fabriqué un monstre
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Nicole dubrachira
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames et
messieurs responsable de texte chers
collègues depuis 2017 nous prenons la
valeur travail au travers de différents
textes qui ont été adoptés comme choisir
son avenir professionnel la réforme de
l'apprentissage et des lycées
professionnels où le régime de
l'assurance chômage et celui dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui sur le plein
emploi l'objectif de ce texte est un
emploi pour tous avec un accompagnement
sociaux professionnel renforcé des
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin en
transformant le service public de
l'emploi et de l'insertion l'objectif
est d'aider les personnes à accéder à
l'autonomie et à la dignité par le
travail et pour chaque entreprise a
recruter dans un contexte d'ombre
d'entre elles rencontrent des
difficultés à pourvoir leur poste
faisant ensuite au rapport de Thibault
guili au commissaire à l'emploi et
l'engagement des entreprises et après
une large concertation territoriale et
nationale
99 propositions ont été faites sur la de
Deep principe dont certains sont
l'inscription pour tous la France
travaille rassembler les acteurs du
service public de l'emploi de
l'insertion dans un réseau France
travail au sein duquel Pôle Emploi
devient opérateur France travail
accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi les
bénéficiaires du RSA en leur permettant
de participer à des activités d'une
durée de 15 inventeurs à viser de
réinsertion progressive faire converger
les droits des travailleurs en
établissement et services d'aide par le
travail avec ceux des salariés améliorer
le développement de l'offre d'accueil du
jeune enfant en rénovant sa gouvernance
dans ce texte à l'article 1
l'inscription pour tous les demandeurs à
France travail et l'orientation vers un
organisme plus adapté à la situation de
chacun sur la base de critères communs
pour identifier les freins bloquants du
retour à l'emploi notamment le logement
la mobilité la garde d'enfants ou les
proches aidants à l'article 2 un contrat
de coopération entre les personnes et
l'organisme responsable pour établir les
objectifs des actions un délai et un
accompagnement nécessaire qu'il soit
professionnel social ou médico-social à
l'article 3 les droits et devoirs des
bénéficiaires du RSA pour éviter les
manquements du RMI concernant
l'insertion en cas de non-respect des
engagements la possibilité de sanction
de type suspension remobilisation pour
inciter la personne à reprendre son
accompagnement avec le versement
rétroactif des sommes limité à trois
mois à l'article 4 et 5 le réseau France
travaille définit des règles communes
pour établir des procédures critères
indicateurs outils numériques et partage
des données dans le respect des règles
administratives les instances de
gouvernance se déclinent à l'échelon
national régional départemental local en
lien avec les missions du réseau chaque
organisme est chargé du repérage du
diagnostic et de l'accompagnement des
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
comme le font aujourd'hui Cap Emploi
l'émission locale l'article 7 une
convention little et la région pour
mettre en œuvre offre nationale de
formation professionnelle en lien avec
les OPCO y compris pour les formations à
distance en gardant une organisation
nationale à l'article 8 enfin afin de
permettre plus d'insertion dans l'emploi
des personnes en situation de handicap
on élargit l'application des
dispositions relatives au titulaires de
la reconnaissance du travailleur
handicapé à toute personne relevant
d'une autre catégorie cela pose le
principe que l'orientation en milieu
ordinaire relève du droit commun sous
les formes diverses cddroplins ou autre
action travail intérimaire et en milieu
protégé une autre option
favorisant l'inclusion on propose aussi
le sac à dos numérique compilation des
aménagements aménagements réalisés dans
le temps et la portabilité de ses
équipements entre les entreprises
toujours avec l'accord de la personne à
l'article 9 en harmonise les droits des
personnes travaillant en ESAT
sur les droits des autres salariés au
moment où une mission étudie aussi la
situation de ces entreprises d'insertion
par le travail pour faire évoluer leur
statut un article 10 le gouvernement
définit des orientations nationales de
l'accueil du jeune enfant à partir des
travaux des 1000 premiers jours du CNR
petite enfance du Pacte des solidarités
pour recenser l'offre et adapter au plus
près les besoins en multipliant les
types d'accueil en rendant plus
attractifs les métiers et en formalisant
les contrôles des établissements
d'accueil des jeunes enfants il confie
aux communes la qualité d'autorité
administrative qui selon le nombre
d'habitants seront chargés en lien avec
les cafés
leur schémas de maintien et
développement de l'offre d'accueil du
jeûne enfant pour les communes de plus
de 3500 habitants et créer un relais
petite enfance pour celle de plus de
10000 habitants cette compétence pour
être transférée à l'intercommunalité et
en cas de difficultés ou de manquement
un accompagnement pour être mis en œuvre
à l'article 11 les adaptations sont
nécessaires pour les territoires
d'outre-mer afin de recenser les
capacités de prise en charge par le
réseau France travail merci de conclure
les possibilités d'accès à l'emploi et
d'accompagnement afin d'éviter de les
plonger dans des difficultés vous avez
compris ce texte d'insertion d'actusion
nous le voterons en l'enrichissant des
amendements mais sans le dénaturer je
vous remercie chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Jocelyn
decigny
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la présidente madame monsieur le
ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues quelle occasion manquait
bien que ce texte apporte quelques
améliorations pour les travailleurs
handicapés ces dernières restent
insuffisantes et non pour objectif que
de les rendre plus employables sans
prendre en compte les freins inhérents
alors situation notamment en termes de
mobilité ainsi le gouvernement pourra
les intégrer au fichier Pôle emploi et
leur supprimer les indemnités RSA s'il
manque à leurs obligations dans le cadre
du contrat d'engagement bien que ce
texte prenne en compte les difficultés
de garde d'enfant véritable frein à
l'emploi et ne répond à cette
problématique qu'en mettant en
difficulté les communes qui vont se voir
attribuer deux forces une compétence
supplémentaire au titre d'autorité
organisatrice de l'accueil du jeune
enfant elle devront alors prendre à leur
charge l'audit de l'offre de garde et
paliers au manque de ceux et dans un
délai écourté en commission cherche
encore comment un maire d'une commune de
9000 habitants va pouvoir estimer le
nombre de places supplémentaires à créer
budgété une opération de construction
d'un établissement recevant du public le
financier et le construire le tout s'il
vous plaît avant le premier janvier 2025
madame la ministre on voit bien là votre
manque de connaissance du fonctionnement
d'une commune et de ses impératifs
administratifs
en ce qui concerne l'objet principal de
ce texte bien que le gouvernement parte
d'un constat juste à savoir la
saturation d'organismes liés à l'emploi
sur le territoire allant de l'échelon
communale au national il n'apporte avec
ce texte aucune solution de fusion pire
encore en regroupant dans une même
gouvernance le préfet les différents
services déconcentrés la commune la
communauté d'agglo et de communes les
départements les régions les partenaires
sociaux il vaut cette nouvelle hydre à
neuf tête un immobiliste me garantit on
imagine déjà des réunions avec tout ce
beau monde autour de la table pour
mettre en place une stratégie commune et
s'accorder une fine que sur la couleur
du papier sur lequel ils noteront le
compte-rendu de cette réunion tout en
programmant la prochaine pour s'accorder
peut-être cette fois-ci sur la couleur
du ciel
ce nouveau né loin d'être le petit
Hercule qu'on souhaiterait voir en lui
se verra donc lourdement handicapé dès
la naissance autre point qui nous laisse
perplexe dans les intentions du
gouvernement c'est la volonté de
regrouper dans un même fichier les
inscris pas d'emploi et les allocataires
du RSA si les premiers recherchent
activement du travail des seconds
regroupent des profils bien différents
tels que des mers au foyer des
procédants des parents d'enfants
atteints de maladies graves les
personnes handicapées en inaptitude
professionnelle ou encore des étudiants
ces personnes ne sont pas demandeurs
d'emploi et pourtant il se verront
demain avec ce texte contraint à signer
un contrat d'engagement de 15 heures
d'activités minimum dans une marche
forcée vers un emploi incompatible avec
leur situation
le terme d'activité n'est d'ailleurs
même pas défini clairement les
hypothèses les plus farfelues peuvent
voir le jour lorsque l'on parle de
resociabilisation en prenant soin de soi
doit-on comprendre qu'elle est chez le
coiffeur ou dans une salle de sport sera
considérée comme une activité
autre point d'abord supprimer au Sénat
le gouvernement veut réintroduire dans
cette version le changement de nom de
Pôle emploi en France travail cela
embrouille et rend ce texte déjà confus
incompréhensible pour les Français quel
gâchis quelle perte de temps et surtout
qu'elle occasion manquée avec ce projet
de loi attendu depuis des décennies par
la profession vous aviez l'occasion de
fusionner tous les acteurs publics de
l'emploi afin de créer un véritable
maillage territorial en répartissant les
agents dans des antennes rurales de
proximité
savez-vous monsieur le ministre qu'il
faut une demi-journée un habitant de
Neuilly-Saint-Front ou de
Villers-Cotterêts pour se rendre à un
rendez-vous de Pôle Emploi assurément
non sinon j'ose imaginer que vous
n'auriez pas proposé un texte si éloigné
de la réalité c'est là que se trouve le
cœur du problème monsieur le ministre
dans la mobilité dans l'accessibilité à
l'emploi pas dans le changement de non
ni de couleur du nouveau logo de France
travail vous l'aurez compris votre loi
sera aussi flou inefficace mais ce qui
est le plus choquant et révélateur de
votre amateurisme c'est que vous ne
l'avez même pas budgété en 8 ans votre
gouvernement a plongé le pays à plus de
3200 milliards d'euros de déficits
publics vous prétendez disposer des 2,7
milliards nécessaires selon vous à sa
mise en place ou allez-vous les trouver
monsieur le ministre et qui va payer la
note je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Philippe Juvin
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
une loi baptisée pleine emploi c'est
très séduisant
c'est surtout très nécessaire car sur le
chômage je le rappelais tout à l'heure
les chiffres ne sont pas bons puisque
nous sommes 23e sur 27 dans l'Union
européenne nous ne sommes donc pas avec
les mauvais élèves nous sommes devenus
les mauvais élèves
5 millions de chômeurs et pourtant je ne
connais pas un seul chef d'entreprise
qui ne me dise pas la même chose il
aimerait embaucher et il trouve personne
alors pourquoi cette situation folle
tout d'abord la formation les écoles ne
forment pas aux vraies besoins du pays
les entreprises
contactent alors que ce sont elles qui
créent des emplois
mais c'est ici le sujet c'est aussi
parce qu'en France nous n'avons pas
assez la culture de l'accompagnement du
travail
que devrait faire notre système social
ramener les gens au travail
que fait notre système social il
désincite du travail
aujourd'hui
en un an un bénéficiaire du RSA au
moyenne reçoit trois contacts du service
public chargé de son accompagnement
trois malheureux coups de fil ou MELS
mais comment voulez-vous que ça marche
quand on ne s'occupe pas des gens comme
on le fait aujourd'hui
alors oui nous voulons que tous les
bénéficiaires du RSA soient inscrits à
Pôle emploi
alors oui nous voulons que tout
bénéficiaire du RSA soit en compagnie
vers l'emploi et qu'il fasse 15 heures
d'activités hebdomadaire obligatoire 15
heures de stage de formation
d'insertion de travail mais avant tout
il faut rompre avec cette idée que le
RSA pourrait être versé sans aucun
accompagnement ni aucune contrepartie
bien sûr parfois nous le savons tous les
circonstances personnelles de
l'intéressé feront que ça ne sera pas
possible il ne pourra pas faire les 15
heures et bien dans ces cas là il fera
moins soit mais il ne doit jamais faire
zéro et ça monsieur rapporteur c'est une
grande différence avec votre texte qui
est écrit de telle manière que les 15
heures pourraient en réalité ne pas être
faite du tout
et nous nous souhaitons que contre le ré
RSA il y est toujours une contrepartie
tous ceux qui peuvent travailler et qui
touchent le RSA doivent travailler
nous proposerons toutefois deux
exceptions pour l'obligation de ces 15
heures à leur demande les personnes en
situation de handicap et les parents
isolés sans gardent d'enfants bien sûr
alors vous dites le RSA est un droit
inconditionnel nous pensons exactement
l'inverse quand on a le RSA on a le
devoir de faire un effort d'insertion
et je vais aggraver mon cas la société a
aussi le droit d'évaluer les efforts que
vous faites parce que le RSA c'est
l'argent des Français
et contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu
les 15 heures c'est pas une sanction
c'est à la fois une participation active
à la société une chance de réinsertion
et cette idée simple que la République
ce sont des droits et ce sont des
devoirs la position juste que nous
souhaiterions nous défendre les
républicains dans cette émission c'est
qu'il faut faire beaucoup plus pour
celui qui travaille qui cherche un
emploi qui se forme beaucoup plus que ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui mais il
faut faire beaucoup moins pour la cité
professionnelle permanent qui lui ne
fait aucun effort et pour celui qui
affirme ne pas vouloir travailler tantôt
voulant bénéficier des aides de l'État
tout ça c'est du bon sens
alors par ailleurs cette loi monsieur le
ministre sont aussi des procédures et de
la paperasse mon collègue louait l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure qui sont encore
trop complexes nous devons simplifier se
maquis de l'insertion et faciliter la
vie des allocataires autre sujet depuis
des années en nous vend des lois de
décentralisation qui sont en réalité des
lois de recentralisation et je le dis
avec gravité les LR seront très
attentifs à ce que ce texte ne soit pas
un nouveau texte de recentralisation
cachée ni de transfert de charge et
c'est vrai que c'est bien de mieux payer
les personnels de crèche la question
c'est qui paiera cette générosité de
l'État si c'était les communes et je
vais faire une mention particulière sur
l'article 10 sur les crèches
l'État n'a pas son mot à dire dans les
politiques communales c'est du bon sens
que l'État s'occupe déjà correctement
des affaires de l'État et qui laissent
les mères décider de leur politique de
crèche enfin il manque à cette loi
d'être financé c'est vrai que c'est un
détail vous avez parlé monsieur le
ministre de financement d'État c'est
mieux que les car les excédents du Nédic
sont là pour être pour apurer la date de
l'inédith en conclusion mes chers
collègues vous avez compris les trois
priorités des républicains de
l'efficacité dans la dépense publique
pas de RSA sans contrepartie et pas de
recentralisation laissez tranquille les
élus locaux et ne leur faites pas payer
la dot je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant Adam Farida
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
collègue vous avez brutalisé le pays
pendant pendant plusieurs mois avec
votre réforme des retraites injustées
injustifiées en bafouant le Parlement en
méprisant les organisations syndicales
en réprimant les manifestants vous avez
fait le choix politique de condamner les
Françaises et les Français à deux
enfermes vous le savez votre réforme des
retraites va faire basculer 100 000
personnes de plus au RSA et plus de plus
de plus de
plusieurs milliers de travailleurs
supplémentaires en situation
d'invalidité
après avoir créé 400000 pauvres
supplémentaires pendant le premier
quinquennat après avoir fait 7 milliards
d'économies sur le dos des chômeurs en
réduisant la durée des droits de
l'assurance chômage vous poursuivez la
répression à l'encontre des plus pauvres
les bénéficiaires du RSA sont déjà
contraints à suivre à survivre avec 600
euros par mois dans ce contexte les
obliger à travailler 15 heures par
semaine c'est les contraintes à
travailler pour 7 euros de l'heure c'est
ouvrir la porte au travail gratuit tous
les salariés du pays entendent votre
message désormais ils seront mis en
concurrence avec les personnes forcées
de travailler pour moins de 600 euros
par mois sans même attendre les
résultats de votre expérimentation vous
prenez le risque de pénaliser des
millions de familles
rendez-vous raté à Pôle emploi plus de
RSA refus d'effectuer les 15 heures par
semaine d'intérim plus de RSA pan de
WiFi vous empêche d'être en visio plus
de RSA par cette brutalisation vous
allez sanctionner des familles entières
et notamment les familles monoparentales
mais peut-être mais comment peut-on
suivre 15 heures de formation quand on
est mère seul avec des enfants à charge
collègues avoir faim et vivre avec la
peur du lendemain n'a jamais permis de
trouver un travail et encore moins
d'atteindre le plein emploi chaque année
le chômage tue directement 14000
personnes en France personne personne
n'est au chômage par plaisir si les gens
sont RSA c'est qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
il y a aujourd'hui une pénurie de
d'emploi en France vous promenez vous
promettiez 33 millions d'embauches en
2022 il n'y a eu seulement que 300 000
emplois créés dans le secteur privé vous
annoncez en grande pompe le chiffre de
2,2 millions de chômeurs alors qu'en
réalité ils sont 7,5 millions sans
emploi
Pôle Emploi propose
1,6 millions d'offres d'emploi alors que
les travailleurs inscrits sur cette
plateforme sont six fois plus nombreux
il ne sert à rien de contraindre les
privés d'emploi alors que c'est l'offre
d'emploi qui est insuffisante
pour ne rien arranger votre projet de
loi prévoit également de poursuivre la
privatisation du service public de
l'emploi après le scandale hors pa après
les révélations chocs concernant les
privatisations de nos EHPAD et de nos
crèches et ben vous vous poursuivez tout
simplement la case du service public
sans de moyens supplémentaires avec une
architecture floue votre réforme va
provoquer des souffrances des
souffrances et des deux côtés du guichet
parce qu'un autre service d'emploi est
possible il y a urgence de refonder un
pôle emploi humain pour les privés
d'emploi mais également pour les agents
pour créer des emplois décents
accessibles et de proximité il est
nécessaire de rétablir une assurance
chômage protectrice et de créer des
garanties d'emplois pour les chômeurs de
longue durée merci
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Nicolas turquois
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
c'est avec le projet de loi pleine
emploi que nous reprenons nos travaux
parlementaires après la pause estivale
et je le dis d'emblée allons-nous saisir
cette opportunité pour faire œuvre utile
collectivement pour nos concitoyens et
notamment les plus fragiles ou allons
nous renouer immédiatement avec des
combats politiques dignes d'une guerre
de tranchées avec l'énergie renouvelée
de la rentrée
sur ces bancs nous nous réclamons
quasiment tous de cet équilibre trouver
la sortie de la guerre entre communistes
égoïste sur une société du travail où
les cotisations des uns permettent la
protection des autres face à la maladie
à l'accident à la perte d'emploi mais
aussi par exemple pour contribuer à
proposer des logements au plus grand
nombre cet équilibre c'est le cœur
Constitutionnel de la sécurité sociale à
la française
ce cœur il est bien malade depuis de
longues années et ce à cause d'un
chômage un taux de chômage endémique
l'effort de cotisation devient
insupportable pour ceux qui travaillent
et la solidarité n'est plus à la hauteur
pour ceux qui en aurait besoin à cause
d'un rapport actif inactif dégradé
notre ambition a été depuis six ans de
ronway avec une société de l'emploi
l'emploi c'est bien sûr de la richesse
économique mais c'est surtout une
richesse sociale avec 2 millions
d'emplois créés depuis 2017 nous avons
été à la hauteur de nos responsabilités
ce n'est pour autant pas suffisant des
millions de gens sont encore exclus de
l'emploi alors que paradoxalement nous
entreprises n'arrivent pas à recruter
à mon sens et c'est en cela que
j'aimerais vous inviter à mettre nos
oppositions politiciennes de côté ce
projet de loi coche toutes les cases du
modèle de société à la française
d'abord une volonté réaffirmée de
développer une société de l'emploi
ensuite le constat qu'il y a des
millions de gens sans emploi en France
mais qu'ils sont très éloignés des
attendus du monde du travail
il nous faut donc dépasser l'approche
uniquement centrée sur la compétence et
la formation
ce projet de loi il répond en proposant
d'abord une meilleure coopération des
différents acteurs de l'emploi des
solidarité car la complexité de notre
organisation et son articulation en silo
est un véritable filet à might trop
large qui ne s'occupe pas de tout le
monde
il faut de la cohérence dans
l'organisation c'est l'ambition c'est
l'ambition du réseau France travail
il faut aussi aborder ces publics
éloignés de l'emploi les considérant
sous 360 degrés
à quoi servira la formation pour telle
ou tel poste si je n'ai pas le véhicule
pour m'y rendre ou si je n'ai pas de
possibilité de faire garder mes enfants
cette approche tout azimut t'a permis
des résultats tangibles chez les jeunes
avec les missions locales ou chez des
personnes en situation de handicap avec
Cap Emploi nous devons la généraliser à
tous ceux éloignés de l'emploi depuis
longtemps et notamment les bénéficiaires
du RSA
la question du RSA sera d'ailleurs au
centre de nos débats j'en suis sûr à
l'image de ce qui s'est passé en
commission et de ce qui vient d'être dit
nous considérons que renforcer
l'inclusion des allocataires du RSA est
à la fois un devoir et une nécessité
la société le doit ces personnes en
souffrance car personne n'a à être
laissé au bord du chemin et dans le même
temps chaque Français peut et à la
responsabilité de contribuer à l'effort
collectif
les bénéficiaires du RSA sont souvent
réduits à des unes identité
stigmatisantes pauvre profiteur oisif
très loin de la réalité pour le plus
grand nombre d'entre eux on ne vit pas
avec 600 euros par mois en survie
de ce texte c'est de leur proposer le
chemin de l'accompagnement progressif
sur toute leur difficulté en les mettant
en condition d'être des acteurs de leur
rebond personnel et professionnels
pour eux comme pour toutes les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
allons-nous nous donner cette
opportunité à travers ce projet de loi
ou allons-nous de nouveau privilégiez
nos oppositions stériles le groupe
démocrate a très très clairement choisi
son camp j'espère que vous en ferez de
même
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Benjamin sans
tuile
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
le ministre madame la présente de
commission monsieur rapporteur madame la
rapporteur après l'assurance chômage
après les retraites voilà le moment
attendu par le gouvernement pour parler
pleine emploi nous sommes surpris chez
Yot que vous ayez choisi ce moment parce
que le calendrier nous semble étrange
nous nous sommes attachés à la valeur
travail au mérite à l'émancipation par
le travail et du coup nous nous
demandons où sont passés les mécanismes
qui privilégie le travail toujours pas
de conférence sociale sur les salaires
qui permettrait de remettre l'église au
milieu du village pardon pour
l'expression permettrait à ceux qui
travaillent de pouvoir en tirer des
fruits suffisants rien jusqu'à présent
sur les conditions de reprise d'emploi
nous avons eu l'occasion d'en échanger
en commission aujourd'hui en France il
existe encore un certain nombre de
situations où la reprise d'emploi est
moins intéressante financièrement que
l'inactivité de manière temporaire il
faut réagir sur ces questions
c'est la condition première pour
atteindre le plein emploi ce calendrier
nous semble étrange quand il s'agit de
parler de ce texte spécifique parce
qu'il ne fait aucune proposition globale
sur les freins à l'emploi à l'exception
de la petite enfance nous y reviendrons
il est aussi surprenant parce que vous
n'avez pas attendu le retour sur les
expérimentations en cours mais soit vous
souhaitez que nous parlions du service
public de l'emploi et du RSA alors
parlons-en certains par le rond de
capacité à vivre voire à survivre
d'autres en feront la définition moderne
de loisiveté et de l'appareil chacun
aura choisi son camp relevons d'abord
que dans un système de droit et de
devoir qui existe déjà à travers le RSA
c'est plutôt du côté des droits que la
défaillance est nette et les chiffres
que vous avez vous-même utilisés
monsieur ministre dans votre
présentation tout à l'heure sur les
allocataires qui restent 5 ou 10 ans
dans les dispositifs témoignent de
l'échec que nous devons essayer de
combattre ensemble
dans ce texte il n'y a malheureusement
que peu de choses sur la question des
droits vous en parler peu et de manière
floue avec des moyens qui resteraient
qui resteront à préciser côté de voir
par contre là vous êtes inspiré
inscription automatique et aveugle une
obligation de 15 à 20h d'activités
conditions sinequanone pour pouvoir
bénéficier du revenu d'assistance et
nouvelle sanctions monsieur le
rapporteur me dira qu'elle est
progressive je lui répondrai qu'elle est
largement plus facilement mobilisable
mais sans doute sans doute sommes-nous
là dans la prison de la parade nuptiale
que vous avez entamé avec les collègues
du groupe LR puisque vous êtes condamné
à trouver avec eux une solution pour que
ce texte soit voté la solidarité
nationale pourtant inscrite dans la
Constitution se déclonne se décline
désormais aux conditionnel la solidarité
oui mais 607 euros
ça se mérite il y a des conditions pour
pouvoir y accéder il y en a qui ont dit
en commission il y en a qui ont dit à
cette tribune il y a encore quelques
instants on ne vit pas avec 6007 euros
ont survit et pourtant vous mettez en
place des mécanismes de suspension qui
vont mécaniquement créer des conditions
d'affaiblissement d'affaissement des
revenus de ces allocataires du RSA vous
prenez le risque de les appauvrir dans
un contexte rappelons-le d'inflation
galopante de pouvoir d'achat ébranlé et
de pauvreté qui continuent
malheureusement à être renforcés nous le
voyons chaque jour sur notre territoire
partout où que nous soyons pourtant il
existait une hypothèse d'une autre
réforme plus juste plus équilibrée basée
sur le mérite une valeur qui est chère à
beaucoup ici d'abord à travers
l'adhésion volontaire et non pas
automatique à un projet qui sera
construit en réciprocité avoir
une réforme plus méritante puisque nous
considérons que ceux qui font les
efforts et qui s'engagent dans un
contrat d'engagement réciproque qu'on
pourrait qualifier de renforcer avec des
heures d'activité cela devrait pouvoir
prétendre à une revalorisation du RSA
une espèce de bonification à ceux qui
font les efforts ou encore évidemment la
possibilité d'interroger le régime des
sanctions et si nous ne sommes pas
fermés à cette hypothèse nous disons que
il faut faire attention à la
disproportion nous nous choisissons des
sanctions de remobilisation qui
n'appauvrissent pas les familles de
manière générale et pour terminer mon
propos les sujets sur la gouvernance
vont dans le bon sens puisqu'il se
rapproche des territoires même si nous
pourrions aller plus loin je veux avoir
un regret au nom des Outre-mer puisque
vous avez choisi l'ordonnance et donc le
silence dans cette hémicycle sur des
sujets aussi importants et relevés des
avancées non négligeables sur la petite
enfance et sur le handicap de manière
générale ce texte semble pour nous être
un texte d'affichage de communication
politique loin malheureusement de la
réalité des Français
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Emmanuelle Ménard
merci
beaucoup madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues
alors que la légère baisse du chômage au
deuxième trimestre 2023 faisait ce
féliciter certains auront desquels vous
étiez monsieur le ministre et laisser
croire au retour du plein emploi force
et de constater que les chiffres du
chômage en France ne sont
malheureusement pas si bon que cela la
France ne se place en effet qu'à la 22e
position sur 27 dans l'Union européenne
avec un taux de chômage qui stagne à
7,1% là où celui de l'Union européenne
s'établissait à 5,9% en juin dernier ce
sont malheureusement les jeunes de moins
de 25 ans qui sont les plus touchés par
le chômage avec près de 17% de chômeurs
sur cette classe d'âge et certains
territoires sont encore frappés par un
chômage de masse je pense notamment à
Mayotte avec une hausse de plus de 22%
de chômeurs sur un an
le titre du texte que nous examinons est
ambitieux et je ne peux que souscrire à
son objectif alors où il n'est pas un
secteur qui ne peine à recruter et où le
plancher des 3 millions de chômeurs ne
semble pas pouvoir être franchie et
au-delà de la manière dont ce sont
déroulés les discussions en commission
vous avouerez que pour un texte de
rentrée ce n'est pas très bonne augure
pour la suite de notre travaux je ne
peux que me féliciter de certaines
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens que
les allocataires du revenu de solidarité
active et leur conjoint soit inscrits au
chômage est une bonne chose avec près de
2 millions de foyers au RSA en hausse de
46% depuis 10 ans et 40% des
allocataires qui ne sont pas inscrits à
Pôle emploi il était temps de même pour
l'obligation de 15 heures d'activité
hebdomadaire pour les allocataires du
RSA et si pour certains députés de
gauche il s'agit d'un recul social
impressionnant voire d'une coercition je
ne peux que déplorer une fois encore
cette triste philosophie du travail
c'est 15 heures ne sont là que pour
aider les demandeurs d'emploi à
retourner sur le marché du travail
rassurez-vous j'en rencontre
suffisamment chez moi à Béziers pour
savoir que les bénéficiaires du RSA ne
sont pas homogène et que si vouloir tous
les remettre au travail et irréalistes
ceux qui ont de gros souci de santé par
exemple il est nécessaire d'aider et
même d'inciter les autres certains sont
trop cassés pour pouvoir travailler dans
le privé mais seront capables de
travailler en emploi aidé cela devrait
avoir les revenus du RSA contraint
d'emploi même très peu qualifiés de 15
heures ou 20 heures par semaine qui leur
redonnerait à la fois stabilité et sens
de leur utilité sociale en bref la
fierté de ne plus être assistée et de
gagner son propre argent d'autres ont eu
une rupture dans leur vie et doivent
rebondir certains de cela ont besoin
d'un délai pour y parvenir mais d'autres
s'accommodent de la situation et pour
certains travaillent au noir et oui
arrêtons de nous mentir eux sont
employables et devraient bénéficier d'un
accompagnement renforcé de Pôle emploi
et d'une date butoir avant de se voir
supprimer leurs droits je crois pour ma
part que la majorité des Français
désirent plus que tout de vivre de leur
travail une question d'amour propre et
de dignité le contrat d'engagement prévu
dans votre projet de loi doit fixer avec
clarté les droits mais aussi les devoirs
des allocataires car là où le
contribuable se voit dans l'obligation
de participer à la solidarité il est
normal d'imposer des devoirs à celui qui
en bénéficié pour rappel le RSA
concentre 60% de
351,4 millions d'euros de versements
frauduleux recensés par la Caisse
nationale d'allocations familiale en
2022 il est fort dommage que votre texte
n'en fasse pas mention quand on nous
répète allons-y que les caisses de
l'État sont vides par ailleurs votre
votre texte suscite de fortes
inquiétudes chez les acteurs de Pôle
emploi car si l'on doit avoir les mêmes
chances de sortir du chômage à Lille et
à Béziers il faut savoir s'adapter aux
spécificités locales vouloir fondre un
outil national avec l'émission locale
d'insertion par exemple témoigne d'une
sérieuse méconnaissance des réalités un
mot enfant sur l'article 10 consacré à
la petite enfance si je m'étonne de le
trouver dans un texte consacré aux
pleins d'emploi je serai
particulièrement attentive à ce que les
communes ne soient pas encore une fois
le dindon de la farce de cette nouvelle
organisation en étant financièrement
impacté par de nouvelles charges
sociales
en conclusion à l'heure où certains
youtubeurs incitent à tricher avec le
système afin de vivre des allocations
alors où l'absentéisme a augmenté de 20%
dans certains secteurs d'activité il est
urgent de redonner envie et fierté de
travailler au français au risque sinon
de voir notre système s'écrouler je vous
remercie
je vous remercie alors Monsieur le alors
madame Lamy
en réaction aux différentes
interventions discussions générales
d'abord pour dire qu'il y a un constat
je crois assez largement partagé nous
avons un chômage qui a baissé chacun
peut s'en féliciter mais nous avons un
chômage qui reste très élevé et parmi
les plus élevés à l'échelle européenne
et malgré ce chômage élevé nous avons
des entreprises qui peinent à recruter
qui rencontre des tensions et au premier
semestre de l'année 2023 les deux tiers
des PME du secteur industriel disaient
même renoncer à des opportunités de
croissance du fait de difficulté de
recrutement et du de difficulté à faire
face à ces mêmes opportunités dans le
même temps nous avons une autre
difficulté qui a été évoquée par
Monsieur sainte-huile comme par Monsieur
juin comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
faire en sorte que pour tous le retour à
l'emploi soit une opération gagnante la
réalité que lorsqu'on regarde la
situation d'un allocataire ou d'une
allocataire d'un minima social
avec un ou deux enfants et que cette
allocataire retrouve un emploi à temps
plein et au SMIC l'opération est
systématiquement positive là où nous
rencontrons une difficulté c'est qu'elle
est parfois positive après 3 4 ou 5
points car les coûts à la reprise
d'emploi par exemple la garde d'un
enfant les pertes de droits liées à
cette reprise d'emplois et de la sortie
d'un système de minima social sont plus
rapides à se mettre en oeuvre et à
toucher le quotidien de ses foyers que
les nouveaux droits liés à une situation
de salariés avec un salaire au niveau du
SMIC et donc c'est cette période un peu
intermédiaire sur laquelle nous devons
travailler pour que le retour à l'emploi
soit véritablement positif et
immédiatement positif quitte à garantir
peut-être à ce que un certain nombre de
droits restent acquis le temps que les
nouveaux droits soient insimisés en
oeuvre c'est une des raisons qui m'ont
amené dans le cadre dans la rédaction de
la lettre de cadrage relatif à la
négociation assurance chômage pour la
question des seniors tout
particulièrement à inviter les
partenaires sociaux à penser des
dispositifs de maintien soit sous forme
de sous forme d'allocations
différentielle d'un certain nombre
d'aide aux demandeurs d'emploi seniors
lorsqu'il reprennent un emploi et qu'il
y a besoin d'accompagner cette reprise
d'emploi nous avons donc cet objectif
cet objectif à la fois de simplification
et cet objectif de pleine emploi de
retour à l'emploi qui soit gagnant à
chaque fois il y a trois points sur
lesquels je souhaite revenir un instant
le premier point concerne la question de
la répartition des compétences et du
débat sur la décentralisation la
déconcentration ou la recentralisation
des politiques de l'emploi j'ai dit dans
mon propos liminaire au tout début de la
science j'ai veillé avec beaucoup
d'attention parce que aucune disposition
du texte pas un alinéa ne remettre en
cause la répartition des compétences
entre l'État et les collectivités
locales pas un seul alinéa ne le permet
ne le prévoit et de la même manière j'ai
veillé à ce que pas un seul alinéa ne
vienne modifier la répartition des
compétences entre les collectivités
locales elles-mêmes parce que je
considère qu'en matière d'organisation
territoriale comme en matière de
répartition des compétences il faut
parfois c'est un peu de temps aux choses
les séchausse s'installer sans vouloir
les modifier de manière systématique et
donc il n'y a pas de recentralisation et
au contraire nous proposons aux
collectivités locales dans un double
pilotage un copilotage au niveau
notamment des parcs mental régional mais
aussi au niveau de l'état des traces
associées à la définition des
orientations du service public de
l'emploi ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et je pense
utile et juste et efficace par ailleurs
que les collectivités leurs mots à dire
sur la définition de ces orientations
que mettent en œuvre l'ensemble des
opérateurs Pôle emploi de ma France
travaille au premier chef mais aussi
l'émission locale mais aussi Cap emploi
et je pense que c'est une question
une condition de l'efficacité parce que
nous savons que pour passer de 7 à 5% de
chômage si nous n'avons pas avec nous un
partenariat avec les collectivités sur
les questions de mobilité sur les
questions de garde d'enfant sur les
questions de logement sur les questions
d'accès aussi à la santé nous ne n'y
arriverons pas et donc c'est le prix de
l'efficacité que de travailler ensemble
sans recentralisation mais plutôt en
donnant du poids aux un S et aux autres
la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner concerne les 15 à 20h
nous sommes convaincus et l'expérience
le monde notamment sur le compte
engagement jeune qu'avec ce niveau de
d'accompagnement ce niveau
d'investissement social nous maximisons
les possibilités de retour à l'emploi
par l'accès à la formation qualifiante
ou l'accès à l'emploi direct cela se
voit cela se démontre et l'objectif
n'est pas de dire que c'est 16h 17h ou
18h qui seraient une condition
d'efficacité nous avons un objectif
entre 15 et 20h il a été dit par tous
que cet accès en tout cas ces activités
d'insertion de formation devaient aussi
tenir compte des difficultés rencontrées
tout à l'heure madame la députée Gaara a
évoqué un témoignage sur une femme mère
d'un enfant si j'ai bien compris avec
des phobies et donc un rôle des dents
pour ce qui la concerne mais aussi un
rôle en tout cas un rôle mais le choix
d'être auto-entrepreneur et mère
célibataire
elle est typiquement dans les publics
qui doivent faire preuve qu'il doit
faire l'objet pardon d'une attention
particulière et même d'une exemption de
ces formes d'activité parce
qu'effectivement elle n'aura pas la
possibilité et qu'à moins de lui
proposer quelque chose de
particulièrement adapté à sa situation
telle que vous l'avez décrite il est
évidemment pensable de pouvoir exiger de
quelqu'un dans la situation que vous
avez décrite 15 à 20h d'activités
supplémentaires j'ai en tête une
allocataire du RSA que j'ai rencontré à
Jean-Louis sans Côte d'Or pour le
lancement des expérimentations
c'est sans même deux cas deux exemples
la première me dit je subis je connais à
la suite d'un accident un handicap qui
me cause des douleurs au dos et à la
jambe je veux travailler et dans mon
parcours tel que décider avec mes
conseillers sociaux d'insertion
professionnelle je prends du temps pour
mener à bien des examens médicaux qui me
permettent de savoir quel type
d'activité professionnelle je peux
exercer sans prendre de risque pour ma
santé sans prendre le risque d'un échec
professionnel cela fait partie de ces
parcours là de la même manière elle
était accompagnée d'une autre jeune
femme
10 ans au RSA avec des enfants mère
célibataire qui a retrouvé une activité
dans une collectivité locale notamment
dans un service de cantine 20 heures par
semaine la question de cette jeune femme
était de me dire mais est-ce qu'on va
m'obliger à faire 15 amateurs
d'activités d'insertion et de formation
pour en plus de mes 20h de travail la
réponse est évidemment non mais la même
me disait je souhaite accéder à un temps
plein et donc si nous pouvons
l'accompagner mobiliser trois heures
quatre heures cinq heures d'activité lui
permettant d'accéder au temps plein
c'est là le bon chemin c'est la
démonstration je crois qu'il faut savoir
adapter mais je le répète ma conviction
et que plus nous aurons d'un locataire
accompagné avec cet investissement
social et avec cet objectif de 15 à 20h
pour être efficace mieux ce sera ça
n'empêche pas de tenir compte de des
capacités des difficultés de chacun je
fais une parenthèse pardon de le dire
ainsi mais pour la situation des
personnes en situation de handicap et
notamment des titulaires de la hache
j'ai entendu il y aura une obligation
d'inscription auprès de Pôle Emploi ça
n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas nous voulons l'inscription
automatique pour les allocataires du RSA
nous voulons l'inscription automatique
pour les jeunes suivies dans les
missions locales dans le cas des jeunes
qui sont suivis par l'émission locale
dans un parcours d'insertion vers
l'emploi nous savons qu'il y en a
d'autres qui bénéficient d'un
accompagnement global et je pense
notamment aux mineurs il est évidemment
hors de question de prévoir
l'automaticité pour ce qui concerne les
personnes en situation d'handicap
bénéficiaire de la hache j'ai dit
répéter mes collègues l'ont dit répéter
que les mesures que nous prenons visent
à favoriser l'accès ou le retour à
l'emploi de ceux qui le souhaitent en
tenant compte de leur particularité et
il n'y a pas d'inscription automatique
pour les titulaires de la hache tel que
nous l'avons prévu dans le texte c'est
sur la base du volontariat et à chaque
fois qu'une personne en situation de
handicap souhaite être accompagné sur le
chemin de l'emploi nous devons les
accompagner nous devons les aider et le
service public de l'emploi doit les
accompagner comme des demandeurs
d'emploi en veillant aux aménagements
sans les renvoyer systématiquement à
leur statut de personnes en situation de
handicap enfin
il y a un certain nombre de sujets qui
ont été abordés sur les questions de
financement je l'ai dit
finalement les décisions sont dans les
mains du Parlement le budget pour 2024
présentera une trajectoire avec 170
millions d'euros pour financer la
contractualisation avec les départements
de France qu'est-ce qui sera derrière
cette contractualisation d'abord la
transition tous les départements vers
France travail ça n'est pas le plus
coûteux mais c'est faire en sorte que
les modèles informatiques les systèmes
d'information puissent commencer à être
partagé et puis il y aura aussi le
financement d'un certain nombre
d'activités comme la garantie
d'activités départementales qui doivent
évoluer vers le modèle France travail
c'est quelques dizaines de millions
d'euros et puis il y a des départements
qui expérimentent 18 d'autres qui
veulent rejoindre l'expérimentation et
cet argent permettra aussi de financer
l'expérimentation pourquoi est-ce que
nous avons fait voter ce projet de loi
avant la fin de l'expérimentation parce
qu'en réalité nous souhaitons que le
projet de loi soit en vigueur pleinement
à partir 2025 et que la meilleure façon
de généraliser un accompagnement d'ici à
2025 c'est de l'expérimenter c'est
d'essayer nous n'allons pas inscrire
dans la loi nous n'allons pas inscrire
décret les modalités pratiques
d'accompagnement ça relève des
politiques départementales et sociales
par contre expérimenter essayez permet
aussi de partager les bonnes pratiques
et d'ici 2025 d'avoir cette capacité à
être efficace par tout sur le territoire
et puis enfin je l'ai dit aussi lundis
qui affiche une trajectoire d'excédent
qui est une trajectoire très importante
et nous prévoyons effectivement que sur
ces excédents lunédiques une partie
permet de financer des politiques de
formation des politiques d'insertion des
politiques de développement de
l'apprentissage parce que ça s'appelle
les dépenses actives et qu'à chaque fois
qu'on accompagne un demandeur d'emploi
vers l'emploi c'est moins d'allocation
bercer c'est plus de cotisations perçue
je le dis et là aussi en réponse à
Monsieur Juvin qu'il a évoqué ce que
nous prévoyons n'empêchera pas uneédique
de se désendetter à hauteur de 50% de sa
dette d'ici la fin du quinquennat c'est
la démonstration que nous pouvons à la
fois permettre à contribution d'une
certaine manière pour le dire très
directement ce système inédit avec des
dépenses actives pour le retour de
l'emploi sans contrarier une trajectoire
des endettement de plus de 50% à
l'échelle du quinquennat ce qui je crois
tout le monde peut en convenir et et
quelque chose de bien et de
d'extrêmement soutenable voilà madame la
Présidente ce que je souhaitais évoquer
avant que mes collègues reviennent sur
les questions notamment liées au
handicap et la petite enfance
je vous remercie madame la ministre vous
avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente peut-être
pour répondre à certaines des
interrogations d'abord sur la question
du non recours au droit l'objectif
évidemment c'est bien d'aller au bout
d'un chantier qui est absolument
déterminant et dont vous savez qu'il
changera profondément nos politiques
publiques si nous y arrivons et nous
devons y arriver quelle est la question
de la solidarité à la source la
solidarité à la source c'est pas juste
le pré remplissage des déclarations ce
qui serait déjà en plus en effet quand
comme ça a été rappelé notamment par
député de la porte mais c'est surtout un
accompagnement qui doit être beaucoup
plus digne des personnes notamment
celles qui sont les plus éloignées c'est
tout l'enjeu de la solidarité à la
source et encore une fois c'est tous les
arbitrages qui sont en cours de manière
à voir qu'elle entra le périmètre de
manière à ce que ce soit effectif
évidemment avant la fin du quinquennat
donc je crois que c'est la meilleure
réponse à la lutte contre le non-recourt
c'est évidemment la solidarité à les
sources et ce sont les territoires zéro
non recours 39 territoire en cours
d'expérimentation sur ces sujets je me
tiens à disposition de chacun si vous le
souhaitez qu'on aille plus loin sur sur
cette bah oui mais expérimenté c'est
permettre justement de faire confiance
au département c'est d'être dans cette
logique de partenariat qu'on doit avoir
avec les départements pour pas tout
imposer du haut mais pour faire ensemble
et je crois que c'est plutôt comme ça
qu'on doit réussir à fonctionner le
ministre du Travail a répondu sur la
question notamment de celles et ceux qui
sont les plus éloignés de l'emploi c'est
beaucoup de cas ont été donnés notamment
la question des procédants on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir début octobre sur
les solutions que nous devons aux
aidants qui se trop souvent s'oublient
qui trop souvent d'ailleurs oublient
leurs propres conditions de santé pour
accompagner les personnes les plus
fragiles et les plus vulnérables dont
elles ont la responsabilité et
évidemment l'idée n'est pas encore une
fois de considérer tout le monde de la
même manière mais bien de prendre en
compte les spécificités et notamment
évidemment cette situation très
particulière des des aidants sur le
handicap ça a été dit c'est tout ce
qu'on défend évidemment avec la ministre
délégué Fadila katabi et je comprends
même pas en vérité que ça puisse faire
polémique que de considérer que par
principe toutes les personnes
handicapées toutes les personnes en
situation de handicap doivent pouvoir
être employables c'est-à-dire qu'on doit
pas les considérer différemment dans
notre société c'est qu'on doit les
considérer comme par principe faisant
pleinement partie intégrant de notre
société et faire en sorte que notre
société s'adapte à elle et non que ce
soit les personnes qui doivent s'adapter
ensuite au contrainte que trop souvent
l'État a pu poser et aux entreprises
évidemment de s'adapter pour le
permettre donc je crois bien s'il y a
vraiment deux articles qui doivent tous
nous réunir c'est vraiment les articles
qui sont consacrés aux personnes en
situation de handicap un mot sur la
fraude même si c'est pas l'objet de ce
texte mais comme plusieurs ils sont
revenus pour vous donner deux chiffres
sur 2022 qui me semble intéressant la
CAF a réalisé plus de 32 millions de
contrôles permettant de régulariser 260
millions d'euros de personnes qui
avaient donc délibérément délibérément
frauder notre modèle social une vidéo a
été malheureusement largement commenté
et partagée j'ai saisi évidemment
euh toutes les instances nécessaires
pour que des contrôles spécifiques sur
cette personne soit mise en place de
manière évidente je crois qu'on peut
tous assumer qu'on a un modèle social
qui est très généreux et tant mieux mais
qu'il est hors de question que certains
l'utilisent un mauvais escient pour le
frauder et on ira même plus loin avec un
délit de promotion de la fraude sociale
comme cela a été mis en place pour la
fraude fiscale si on veut garder un
modèle social généreux et solide il faut
être impitoyable avec ceux qui de
manière délibérée veulent frauder notre
modèle social et veulent donc tricher et
encore plus quand ça ose concerner la
location adulte handicapé je trouve que
voilà je pense que ça a été assez
commenté mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire de rappeler quelques
principes
enfin et j'imagine que dans le débat on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir sur encore
une fois l'article 10 qui crée le
service public de la petite enfance tout
l'objectif de la manière avec laquelle
nous avons cheminé réécrit depuis la
version du Sénat on n'a pas écrasé ce
qui avait été fait par le Sénat au
contraire on a gardé beaucoup
d'évolution qui viennent du Sénat
pourquoi parce que l'objectif c'est
d'assumer d'avoir une méthode là encore
partenariale avec les collectivités on
ne réussira pas le service public de la
petite enfance contre les mers contre
les collectivités on ne réussira que
grâce à eux c'est la raison pour
laquelle on renforce en vérité leur
prérogative non seulement on assume de
dire bah oui des facto vous êtes les
pilotes parce que vous avez réussi à
déployer en général dans vos
collectivités un service public quel
qu'en soit après les modalités
délégation de service public ou autre je
pense qu'il aide aussi il faut assumer
qui est plusieurs modèles qui puissent
coexister on renforce le pouvoir des
mers parce qu'on leur donne un pouvoir
d'avis préalable qui n'existait pas
aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
s'installer en vérité créer ici une
micro crèche etc nous on veut renforcer
le pouvoir des mers justement pour
qu'ils aient un avis préalable ce qui
n'existait pas encore une fois et
surtout on veut les accompagner parce
que beaucoup de mères aujourd'hui ce
qu'ils nous disent c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens de leurs ambitions en
matière d'accueil du jeune enfant parce
qu'ils n'ont pas l'ingénierie nécessaire
pour y parvenir parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens nécessaires pour le financer
c'est pour ça qu'encore une fois il y a
6 milliards d'euros qui sont mis sur la
table de 2023 2027 pour garantir qu'on
donne les moyens au CAF évidemment moyen
budgétaire et financier et moyen humain
d'accompagner les collectivités Charles
et disposition de tous les
parlementaires le courrier du président
de l'AMF qui fait état justement du
dialogue je crois très fructueux et
utile que nous avons eu ensemble et qui
garantit un compromis que nous avons
trouvé pour encore une fois garantir
tout simplement que nos enfants puissent
être accueillis dans les meilleures
conditions possibles je vous remercie
je vous remercie la discussion générale
et close et je suspends pour deux
minutes